hey everyone this is keith now
simply learn welcome to this video on
microsoft as your full course
in this full course we will learn
everything about azure in detail
with an introduction to what microsoft
is here is
then we will look into its concepts in
detail
our experts will give you a quick
training on azure services
moving forward we will understand as
your machine learning
as your active directory and as your
virtual network
after that we will be looking into few
major differences between
aws and azure and then
we will have a quick understanding of
how the famous cloud providers
aws azure and gcp are different
from each other finally we will conclude
this video by discussing the top 25
important as your interview questions
and answers
for beginners and experience level
candidates
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your azure related queries
would have been answered
for this training with me i have our
experienced azure expert
sam rahu and alan
together we will take you through the
various topics of azure
so let's start with an exciting video on
the microsoft azure cloud provider
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon
never miss an update from simplylearn hi
guys this is rahul from simply learn and
today we'll be talking about one of the
fastest growing
and second largest cloud computing
platform in the market right now
i'm talking about microsoft azure now
before we begin
let's talk about what we'll be covering
in this video first we'll talk about why
you should be interested in cloud
computing
what exactly is cloud computing what is
microsoft azure
some of its services and the uses of
azure
now let's start with why you should be
interested in cloud computing
now let's say you have an idea for a
revolutionary application
an idea that ticks both the boxes when
it comes to good
applications one it has great user
experience
and two it'll be highly profitable now
for it to be successful
you'll have to release it on the
internet people need to use it they need
to spread the word
and then it'll become truly famous
however for that
you're going to need servers storage
developers
a dedicated network and application
security to ensure your application
works the way it does now these are a
lot of components
and that's where the problem lies there
are two major disadvantages to this
approach
the initial setup is very expensive and
risky
which means this requires a huge amount
of capital up front to ensure
that it works properly and the downside
is if your
application does not become famous or it
doesn't return as much as you expect it
to you're probably not going to get the
money back
which means it provides a huge amount of
risk and then
on the flip side if it does become
famous your number of users have
increased
which means that you'll have to buy more
servers and storage systems to keep up
with your demand
and this problem can be solved with the
help of cloud computing
now that you know why you should be
interested in cloud computing let's go
into the details of
what exactly is cloud computing now
cloud computing is basically a platform
that gives you access to a number of
computing resources
and this is possible with the help of
the internet now as a user
all you need to do is go to a cloud
service provider through your laptop
or your computer through the internet of
course connect
to that cloud service provider and then
there you go you have access to
computing resources now computing
resources may include you know
serverless computing virtual machines
storage
and so much more now let's dig a little
deeper
now basically these cloud service
providers actually have massive data
centers
now in these data centers what you have
are hundreds of servers
also included are storage systems and
mainly
several organizations critical
components so these are very secure
safe locations where a large amount of
data is stored hence the name data
centers
now it is to these data centers that
users actually connect to
collect their data or use it so actually
users can access
any service based on the requirement now
like i told you there's a number of
services the user can use
for example now if you want a
notification every time someone sends
you a message
or perhaps once you get an email you
need a copy of it created
now for all of this there are services
and most importantly
almost every cloud service provider has
this option where
users only pay for the service that they
use
so there's no charge up front where they
tell you that you need to pay x amount
of money so that you can use our
services
you're only paying for the amount of
time that you're using these services
now cloud computing is used for a wide
variety of reasons
firstly there's machine learning and
data analysis now basically
there are services that analyze your
data and tell you how you can work with
this data better
then there's data storage and backup
streaming media content for example did
you know that the shows that you watch
on netflix
actually all of them are in the cloud so
you're connected to the internet
and you browse through netflix and you
get access to the videos
these are possible with the help of
cloud service providers
there's creating and testing
applications automating software
delivery which is
a component in devops and hosting blogs
and applications
so now what is azure what's the big
cloud service provider
all about so azir is a cloud computing
platform
provided by microsoft now it's basically
an online portal
through which you can access and manage
resources and services
now resources and services are nothing
but you know you can store your data
and you can transform the data using
services that microsoft provides
again all you need is the internet and
being able to connect to the azure
portal
then you get access to all of the
resources and their services
in case you want to know more about how
it's different from its
rival which is aws i suggest you click
on the top right corner and watch the
aws versus
your video so that you can clearly tell
how both these cloud service providers
are different from each other now here
are some things that you need to know
about this year
it was launched in february 1st 2010
which is significantly later
than when aws was launched it's free to
start and has a pay-per-use model which
means like i said before
you need to pay for the services you use
through azure
and one of their most important selling
points is that 80 percent of fortune 500
companies
use as your services which means that
most of the bigger companies of the
world
actually recommend using azure and then
azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages
the c-sharp node.js java and so much
more
another very important selling point of
azure
is the amount of data centers it has
across the world now
it's important for a cloud service
provider to have many data centers
around the world
because it means that they can provide
their services to a wider audience
now azure has 42 which is more than any
cloud service provider has at the moment
it expects to have 12 more in a period
of time which brings its
total number of regions it covers to 54.
now let's talk about azure services
now azure services have 18 categories
and more than 200 services
so we clearly can't go through all of
them it has services that cover compute
and machine learning integration
management tools identity
devops web and so much more you're going
to have a hard time trying to find a
domain
that azure doesn't cover and if it
doesn't cover it now
you can be certain they're working on it
as we speak so first let's start
with the compute services first virtual
machine
with this service what you're getting to
do is to create a virtual machine of
linux
or windows operating system it's easily
configurable you can
add ram you can decrease ram you can add
storage remove it
all of it is possible in a match of
seconds now let's talk about the second
service
cloud service now with this you can
create a application
within the cloud and all of the work
after you deploy it
deploying the application that is is
taken care of by azure which includes
you know provisioning the application
load balancing ensuring that the
application is in good health
and all the other things are handled by
azure
next up let's talk about service fabric
now with service fabric
the process of developing a micro
service is greatly simplified
so you might be wondering what exactly
is a micro service
now a micro service is basically an
application that consists of smaller
applications
coupled together next up functions now
with functions
you can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components
you don't have to worry what ram you
require or how much storage you require
all of that is taken care of by his year
all you need is to provide the code to
azure
and it will execute it and you don't
have to worry about anything else
now let's talk about some networking
services first up we have azure cdn
or the content delivery network now the
azure cdn service
is basically for delivering web content
to users
now this content is of high bandwidth
and can be
transferred or can be delivered to any
person across the world
now these are actually a network of
servers that are placed
in strategic positions across the world
so that the customers can
obtain this data as fast as possible
next up we have express route
now with this you can actually connect
your on-premise network
onto the microsoft cloud or any of the
services that you want
through a private connection so the only
communication that happens is between
your on-premise network
and the service that you want then you
have virtual network
now with virtual network you can have
any of the azure services
communicate with each other in a secure
manner in a private manner
next we have azure dns so azure dns is a
hosting service
which allows you to host their dns or
domain name system domains
in azure so you can host your
application using azure dns
now for the storage services first up we
have disk storage
with this storage you are given a cost
effective option of choosing
hdd or solid state drives to go along
with your virtual machines based on your
requirements then you have blob storage
now this is actually optimized to ensure
that they can store
massive amounts of unstructured data
which can include text data
or even binary data next you have file
storage which is a managed file storage
and can be accessible via the smb
protocol
or the server message block protocol and
finally you have
queue storage now with queue storage you
can provide
durable message queuing for an extremely
large workload
and the most important part is that this
can be accessed from anywhere in the
world
now let's talk about how azure can be
used firstly for application development
it could be any application mostly web
applications
then you can test the application see
how well it works you can host the
application on the internet
you can create virtual machines like i
mentioned before with the service you
can create
these virtual machines of any size or
ram that you want
you can integrate in sync features you
can collect and store
matrices for example how the data works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it
all of that is possible with these
services and your virtual hard drives
which
is an extension of the virtual machines
where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored
i'm sam an azure cloud architect working
for simplyland and i'm
more than glad to walk you through this
session where we're going to
talk about azure in great length and
breadth and if you're looking for a
video that
talks and walks you through all the
services in azure
then this could be one of the best video
you could find in the internet
and without any further delay let's get
started everybody like story is it
so let's get started with the story in a
city not so far
away as ceo had plans to expand
his company globally and called one of
his id personnel for an i.t
opinion and this guy has been in the
company for a long time and is
very seasoned with the company's infra
and he nicely answered the questions
with what he foresaw
and he said i have a good news and a bad
news for us to go
global and he starts with the good news
he said
sir we're well on our way to become one
of the world's largest
shipping company and the bad news is
however our data centers have almost run
out of space and setting up new ones
around the world would be too expensive
and very
time consuming now the i.t personal
let's call him mike
now he explains the situation from how
he saw it
but the ceo had done some homework
about how he was going to do it and he
answered mike
saying don't worry about that mic i've
come up with a solution for a problem
and it's called microsoft azure well
mike is an hard-working and honest id
professional
working for that company but he did not
spend time
on learning the latest technologies and
he asked this question very honestly
oh how does it solve a problem and the
ceo begins to explain
azure to mike and he starts with what is
cloud computing and then he goes on and
talks about
azure and the service is offered by
azure and why azure is
better than the other cloud providers
and
what are the great companies that uses
azure and how they got benefited out of
it
and then he winds it all up with the use
cases of
azure so he begins his explanation
saying
microsoft azure is known as the cloud
service
provider and it works on the basis of
cloud computing now microsoft azure is
formerly known as
windows azure and it's a microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it also
provides
a range of cloud services including
some of them are compute analytics
storage
and networking we can always pick and
choose from these services
to develop and scale our applications or
even
plan on running existing applications in
the public cloud
microsoft azure is both a platform as a
service
and infrastructure as a service let's
now fit their conversation out and let's
talk about
what is cloud computing azure services
offered
by azure how is azure leading
when compared to other cloud service
providers and
what are the companies that are using
azure let's talk about that
in simple terms cloud computing is being
able to access
compute services like servers
storage database networking
software analytics intelligence and lot
more
over the internet which is the cloud
with the
flexibility of the resources that we use
like anytime i want a resource i can use
one and it becomes available immediately
and anytime if i want to retire and
results i can simply retire at resource
and not pay for it
and we also typically pay only for the
services
that we use and this helps greatly with
our
operating costs to run our
infrastructure more efficiently and
scale
our environment up or down depending on
the business needs and changes
and all the servers and storages and
databases
and networking all that are accessed
through
the network of remote systems or remote
computers
hosted in the internet typically in
the provider's data center which is
azure
in this case now we don't use any
physical server or an on-premises
server here well we still use physical
servers
and vms you know hosted on a hardware or
a physical server
but they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit
on premises or in our data center we
only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same
except for the fact that they are in a
remote location we access them remotely
do all the work remotely and when we're
done we can
shut it down and not pay for them so
some of the use cases
some of the use cases of cloud computing
are
creating applications and services the
other use cases
are storing or using cloud for
storage alone if there is one thing that
ever grows in their organization
is the storage every new day there is a
new storage requirement
and it's very dynamic it's very hard to
predict
and if we go out and buy a big
storage capacity up front until we use
the storage capacity fully the empty
storages
you know we're wasting money on them so
instead i can go for a storage with
scales
dynamically that's in the cloud put
storage or put data in the cloud
and pay only for what you're storing and
for the next month if
you have deleted or flushed out some
files or data pay less for it
so it's a very dynamic storage in the
cloud and a lot of companies are getting
benefited from
storing data in the cloud because of its
uh
dynamic in nature and the cost that
comes along
with it the cheap cost that comes along
with it and also
they give a lot of the providers like
azure
they give a data replication for free
they promise an sla along with the data
we store in the cloud
so there's an sla attached to it and
they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the
physical disk where our data is stored
azure
automatically makes our data available
from
the redundant or other places where it
had
stored our data because of the sla they
wanted to keep
the other use case for azure is hosting
websites and running blogs using the
compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream
the music azure is a good place to
store music and stream the music with
the benefit of cdn
content delivery network which allows
us to stream a video or audio files with
great speed
you know with that with azure our audio
or video application works seamlessly
because
they are provided to the client with
very low latency and that
improves the customer experience for our
application
azure compute service is a good place
for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
software's embedded softwares that we
can buy
using azure and everything on a
pay-as-you-go
service model so anytime we need a
software we can
go out and immediately buy the software
for
the next one or two hour let's say and
use them and then return it back
we're not bound to any yearly licensing
cost by that azure computing services
has analytic available for us with which
we can
analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network be it logs
be the performance be the metrics you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and
trying to do manual things over the
heaps and heaps of logs that we have
saved
azure analytics services helps us to get
a good
visual of what's going on in the network
where have we dropped where have we
increased or what's causing what's the
major driver what is the top 10 errors
that we get
in the server in the application stuff
like that those can be
easily gathered from the azure
analytic services now cloud is really a
very cool term
for the internet a good analogy would be
looking back anytime we look at a
diagram
when we do not know how things are
transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a male gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country
a lot of things happening in between
from the time you hit the send button
and
the time the other person hits the read
button right and we
the the simple and the easiest way of
putting it in a picture is simply draw a
cloud
and on the one end one person will be
sending the email and
on the other end the other person will
be reading the email so a cloud is a
really cool term
for the internet now that's some basics
about
cloud computing now that we've
understood about cloud computing in
general
let's talk about microsoft azure as
a cloud service now microsoft azure
is a set of cloud services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network
with the help of microsoft azure's
frameworks
now microsoft azure is a computing
service created by
microsoft basically for building testing
deploying
and managing applications and services
through
a global network of microsoft managed
data centers
now microsoft azure provides sas
which is software as a service and pass
which is
platform as a service and iaas
infrastructure as a service and they
support
many different programming languages
tools and
framework and those tools and framework
include both
microsoft specific and third-party
software
now let me pick and talk about a
specific service for example
management azure automation provides a
way for us to automate
the manual long running and frequently
repeated tasks
that are commonly performed tasks both
in cloud and enterprise environment
it saves a lot of time and increases the
reliability
and it kind of gives a good
administrative control
and even schedules the task
automatically to be performed
on a regular basis to give you a quick
history of
microsoft azure it was launched on first
february 2010
and it was awarded or it was called an
industry
leader for infrastructure and platform
as a service
by a gartner now gartner is the world's
leading research
and advisory company this microsoft
azure supports a number of programming
languages like c sharp
java and python all these cool services
we get to use and pay only for how much
we use for example if we use for an r we
only get to pay for an r even the
costliest
system available if you use them for an
r we only pay for
that particular r and then we're done no
more
billing on the resource that we have
used a microsoft azure has spread itself
more than 50 regions around the world
so it's quite easy for us to pick
a region and you know start provisioning
and running our applications
probably from day one because the
infrastructure
and the tools and technologies needed to
run our application are already
available
all that we have to do is commit the
code in that particular region or
build an application and launch it in
that particular region
and they become live starting day one
now because we have 50 regions around
the world
we can very carefully design our
environment
to provide low latency services to our
customers
all right instead of in traditional data
center let's say
you know customers will have to or their
request
will have to travel all the way around
the globe
to reach a data center which lives in
the other side
of the planet and this adds more latency
to it and
it is really not feasible to build a
data center
near each customer location because of
the cost
involved but with azure it's possible
azure already has
data centers around the world and all
that we have to do is just pick a data
center
build an environment there they are
available starting day one
number one and also the cost is
considerably
saved because we are using a public
cloud instead of an physical
infrastructure to serve those customers
from a very local location and these
services that azure
is offering is ever increasing as of now
as we speak
we have like 200 plus services
offered and they span through different
domain or different platform or
different technologies
available within the azure console
portal now we're going to talk about
that later
in this section so hold your breath till
we talk about it
but for now just know that we have like
200 plus
services offered by azure
let's now talk about different services
and azure starting with
artificial intelligence plus machine
learning
where we have a lot of tools and
technologies
so the wide variety of services
available on azure
includes artificial intelligence plus
machine learning
plus analytic services to get an
or to give us a good visual of how the
data
or how the application is performing or
the type of the category of data stored
and to read from the logs and variety of
compute services different vms with
different size and different operating
systems
different containers available different
type of databases available
a lot of developer tools that are
available for us
and identity service to manage
our users in the azure cloud
and those users can be integrated or
federated with
let's say google facebook you know
linkedin so there are some external
federation services they can be used
to integrate with our identity system
iots iot services iot tools and
technologies available
and management tools to manage the users
creating identity is one and then
managing them
on top of it is a totally different
thing and we have
tools technologies to manage the users
cool services for data migration data
migration is now
made simple tools and technologies
available for mobile application
development and i can plan my own
network in the cloud with the networking
services
i can implement my own security both
azure provider and third-party security
services on azure cloud that's now
possible
and a lot of storage options available
in the cloud so these are
just a glimpse of the big list of
services
available in azure cloud so that was a
glimpse of what's available in the cloud
let's talk about the services in a
specific let's take compute
for example you know whenever we're
building a new application or deploying
existing ones
the azure compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application
we have the option of choosing windows
or linux wear machine and
take the advantage of the flexible
options
azure provides for us to migrate our vms
to azure and lot more and these compute
services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in
on-premises and lot more let's look at
some of the
services that this compute domain
provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are
virtual machines and this azure virtual
machines
gives us the ability to develop and
manage a virtual computer environment or
a virtualized
environment inside azure's cloud
environment that do
in a virtual private network now we will
talk about virtual private network at a
later point
but as of now just i know that there are
a lot of services available in
azure compute servers that we can get
benefited from
we can always choose from a very wide
range of
compute options for example you know we
have an option to choose the operating
system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in
on premises or in the cloud or do we
want to maintain the environment both in
on premises and
in the cloud we have the option of
choosing the operating system whether we
want to use our own operating system
with some software attached to it or do
we want to go
and buy the operating system from the
cloud from
azure marketplace and these are just
a few of the options available for us
when we want to buy
the compute environment and these
computer environments are
easily scalable meaning we can easily
scale our vm instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines
in a matter of minutes or simply put in
a couple of button clicks
and all these services are available on
a pay
for what we use model meaning there is
no upfront cost
we use the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there is no
literal long term commitment when it
comes to
using virtual machines in the cloud
and these most of the services are built
on a
pay-per-minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
pay-per-minute billing model
at no point we will be overpaying for
any of the services that's that's
attractive
isn't it now let's talk about batch
service
now batch service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or linux it's gonna
run fairly well and with batch servers
we can take advantage
of the environment's unique features and
not only that in short the batch service
helps us to manage
the whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
azure batch service is actually runs on
a large
scale parallel in high performance
computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in azure
and when we run bad services this azure
batch
creates a pool of computer nodes and
installs the needed applications that we
want to run
and then it schedules jobs to those
individual
nodes in those pools as a customer there
is no need for us to install a cluster
or there is no need for us to install a
software that actually
can use the jobs or even to manage or
even to scale
those infrastructure are the software
because everything is managed by azure
and this batch service is a platform as
a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except
for i mean the only charges that we'll
be paying is
for the virtual machines that the
service uses
and the storage that we will be using of
course and
the networking services that we would be
using for this batch
service let's summarize this bad service
we have a choice of operating system
that we can
pick and use and it scales by itself
now the alternative for the batch would
be queues but in queues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure
even if we're not using it but with a
batch
we only pay for what we use and this bad
service helps us to manage
the application manage the scheduling as
a
whole as if they are just one thing as
next thing
in the compute domain let's talk about
this fabric
service now this fabric service is
actually a distributed
system platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable
and a very reliable microservice and
containers
and what does it help this azure fabric
service helps us
or it helps the developers and
administrators so they can
avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads
or taking care of their development
taking care of their application instead
of spending time on infrastructure
so what service fabric service fabric it
provides runtime capabilities
and life cycle management two
applications
that are composed of micro services no
infrastructure management at all
and with service fabric we can easily
scale the application
to tens or hundreds or even to thousands
of machines
here machines represent containers as
next thing in compute domain let's talk
about
virtual machine scale set now this
virtual machine scale set it lets us
to create a group of identical load
balanced
vms i just want to mention it again it
helps us to
manage a group identical and load
balanced
vms the number of instances or the
number of vm instances
in an in a scale set can increase or
decrease
in response to the demand or in response
to a schedule that we define
you know the resources needed on a
monday morning is not the same as that
would be required on
a saturday or a sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed
in the beginning of the business hour is
not the resources that would be needed
at noon or you know after eight or nine
in the evening so the demands could
actually vary
in the environment and the skill set
helps us to take care of the varying
demand
or take care of the different
infrastructure requirement
at a different schedule throughout the
day throughout the week throughout the
month or could be throughout the year as
well
the skill set also allows us to provide
high availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large
number of vms as if they they are just
one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are
enough why would we need a virtual
machine scale set just like i said
this virtual machine skill set helps us
with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications
and those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes
other requests to the application
instances so
in a nutshell this virtual machine scale
set uh it helps us to
create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one
and with scale set we can increase or
decrease the virtual machines
with virtual machine scale set we can
centrally manage
and configure and update a big group of
vms
and it's a great use case when it comes
to big data or
container workloads as next thing in
compute domain
let's talk about cloud services now this
azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that
support scalability or an application
that requires scalability or reliability
and and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive
to operate so azure cloud service
provides all these
so where would this cloud service run
well it runs on a vm
but it's a platform as a service vms are
infrastructure as a service and when we
run applications on vm
through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service
so here is how you got to be thinking
with infrastructure as a service
like vms we first create and configure
the environment
and then we run applications on top of
it let's look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in vm is that
we manage everything end to end like
you know deploying new patches picking
the versions of the operating system and
making sure they are
intact and all that stuff it's all
managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
i mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform
i mean manage the platform not as an
administrator because all the
administration is taken care
by azure like deploying new versions of
the operating system it's all
handled by the azure so we deploy the
application
and we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
where we can
write the application code and we don't
have to worry about hardware simply hand
over the code and
cloud service takes care of it so no
worry on the hardware
at all so responsibilities like patching
what do we do if something crashes
how do i update the infrastructure how
do i manage
the maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure
all that is handled by azure it also
provides a good
testing environment for us you know we
can simply run the code
test it before it's actually released to
the production
i want to expand a bit on these testing
applications
so this azure cloud service it actually
gives us an staging environment for
testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application tested and
anytime that's ready for production all
that's needed for us to do
to move it to production is simply to
swap the staging environment into the
production
environment and the old production
environment will now become the new
staging environment
where we can add more to it and then
swap it back
at a later point so it kind of gives us
unswappable
environment for testing our applications
and not only that it gives us
health monitoring alerts it helps us to
monitor the health and availability of
our application
and there is a dashboard we can benefit
from
when we use azure cloud services and
that shows the key statistics
all in one place and we can also set up
real-time alerts
to one when a service availability or a
certain metrics
that we are concerned about degrades as
next thing in compute domain let's talk
about
functions now functions are serverless
computing
many times if you heard about azure
being serverless
a lot of time they are referencing or
the person who's talking to you is
referencing to
serverless computing or azure functions
which is a serverless
computing service hosted on microsoft
azure the main motive of a function is
to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run
code on demand without we need to
pre-provision
or manage any azure infrastructure so
azure functions
are script or a piece of code that gets
run
in response to an event that you want to
handle
so in short we can just write a code
that you need for a problem
at hand without actually worrying about
the whole application or the
infrastructure that will be running
that code and the best of all the best
is when we use functions we only pay for
the time that our code runs
so what does functions provide or what
does azure functions provide
azure functions allow users to build
applications using
serverless simple functions with a
programming language of our choice so
the current programming languages that
are supported
is c f sharp node.js java and php
so here we really don't have to worry
about provisioning or maintaining
servers
if a code requires more resource yes
azure functions
handles or it provides the additional
resources
needed by the court and the best part is
we only pay for the amount of
time the functions are running not the
resources but
the amount of time the function is
running
as next thing and moving to the new
domain let's talk about the container
domain in azure
now the container domain or the
container service it allows us to
quickly
deploy a production ready kubernetes or
a
docker swarm cluster now what's a
container a container is a standard unit
of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies
so the applications run quickly and
reliably
from one computing environment to
another it could be
a testing to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production
or on premises to cloud or one cloud
to another cloud vice versa now imagine
we had an option not to worry about the
vm and just focus on the application
well that's exactly what containers
helps us achieve so these container
instances
enable us to focus on applications and
not worrying about managing
vms or not worrying about the learning
the new tools
required to manage the vms or even
the deployment and our applications that
we create
they run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage
the virtual machines so these containers
they can be deployed
into the cloud using a single command if
you're using
a command line interface and a couple of
button clicks if
we are using the azure portal and these
containers are kept
lightweight but they are equally secure
as virtual machines
let's talk about container services next
thing the container service or
sometimes called as azure kubernetes
service
it helps us to manage the containers
container is one thing
and a service that's used to manage the
container is another thing
now this kubernetes service or acs it
helps us to manage
the containers so let's expand on this
a bit so this azure container service or
acs it it actually provides a way
to simplify the creation configuration
and management of a cluster of virtual
machines
that are pre-configured to run
containerized applications on top of
them
and deploying them deploying these
containers
might take like 15 to 20 minutes or
deploying the virtual machines that run
containers
in it might take 15 to 20 minutes and
once they are provisioned we can
actually manage them
by using simple ssh tunnel into them and
this acs
when it runs application it runs
applications from docker images
what does that mean a docker images
makes sure that
the applications the container runs are
fully
portable images are portable and acs
also helps us
to orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that
these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even
tens of thousands of containers so in a
nutshell
managing an existing application into a
container and running it
using aks or acs is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is made simple using this container
services
and even training of model using a large
data set in a complex and
resource intensive environment this aks
helps us to simplify
that environment all right as next thing
in container domain
let's talk about container registry we
spoke about
registry a little bit when we spoke
about docker images so container
registry is a single place where
we can store our images which are docker
images when we
use when we use containers it's it's
docker images that we use
for our image purposes so these
container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage
and management of container images so
there we can store all kinds of images
like
docker swamp or the images used in
docker swarm are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in azure
now anytime we store a container image
it
provides us an option for geo
replication
what that means is that we can
efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now these jio replication it
actually enables us to manage global
deployments
assuming we are having an environment
that requires a global deployment
so it helps us to manage global
deployments as one entity because
we are geo-replicating we would be
updating we would be
editing one image and that image gets
replicated throughout
the global replication centers we would
have set up
and so just one editing would have
actually edited
the global images and those global
images would have
provisioned the global application so
one edit
replication and then provisioning of the
applications
global wide and this replication also
helps us to
helps us network latency because you
know anytime an application
needs to deploy it does not have to rely
on a single source which
which can be reached only through high
latency network because we have global
replications around
the world anytime the application wants
to check back
it would check back the application
which is
in a very nearby location for the
application itself
global replication means that we are
managing it as a single entity
that's being replicated across the
multiple
regions in the globe as next thing in
our learning let's talk about
azure databases now these azure
databases
are rational in fact they have
many flavors in them we're going to look
at different uh
flavors no sql nosql cache type
of database that azure offers so we're
going to learn one at a time
or we're going to learn one by one so
this azure sql database is a
relational database in fact it's a
relational database as a service
it's managed by azure we don't get to do
a lot of management in it so it's a
regional database as
a service based on microsoft sql
server database engine and this database
is
a high performance database it's very
reliable
and it's very secure as well and this
high reliability
high performance and for this high
security really don't have to do
anything it comes along
with it and it's managed by azure
and there are two things that i
definitely need to mention about azure
sql database
that is it's an intelligent service
number one it's fully managed by azure
and it also has this one good thing
which is
it has built-in intelligence that learns
app patterns
and adapts to maximize performance and
reliability
and data protection of the application
that's something that's not
found in many of the other cloud
providers that i'm aware of
so i thought i'll mention it so it uses
built-in intelligence to learn about
the user's database patents and helps
improve performance and
protection and migration or importing
data
is very easy when it comes to azure sql
database so it can
be readily or immediately used for
analytic reporting and
intelligent applications in azure as
next thing let's talk about azure
cosmodb now azure cosmodb is a database
service that
is for nosql type and it's it's created
to provide low latency and
an application that scales dynamically
or that scales rapidly
now this azure cosmodb is an a globally
distributed service and it's a
multi-model
database this can be provisioned in a
click of
a button that's all we got to do if we
need to provision
and azure cosmodb in the azure it helps
with
scaling the database now we can
elastically and independently
scale throughput and storage across this
database
and in any of the azure geographic
regions it provides a good throughput
it provides good latency it provides
good availability
and it provides or azure promises a
comprehensive sla
that no other database can offer that's
the best part about cosmodb
so this cosmodb was built with a global
distribution in mind
and it's built with the horizontal scale
in mind and all this we can use
by only paying for what we have used
and remember the difference between
azure cosmodb and the sql database
is that azure cosmodb supports nosql
whereas sql
doesn't alright few other things about
azure cosmodb is
it allows users to use key value graph
a column family and document data it
also gives users a number of ap
options like sql javascript mongodb and
and few others
that you might want to check the
document at the time of reading and the
best part here is that all that
we mentioned we get to use only by
paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required
and the storage and the throughput can
be elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that r
all right let's talk about um that is
cash discussion about azure database
won't be complete without we talking
about redis cash now redis cash is a
secure data cache it's also called it's
also sometimes called as messaging
broker
that provides high throughput and low
latency access to data for the
applications now
redis cache is based on an a popular
open source
caching product which is redis sometimes
called as that is cache
now what's the use case it's typically
used to cache
uh to improve the performance and
scalability of a system
that rely heavily on backend data stores
now performance
when we use zs cache is improved by
temporarily copying
the frequently accessed data to a fast
storage
located very close to the application
now with redis cache this fast storage
is located in memory with redis cache
instead of being loaded from the actual
disk in
the database itself now this redis cache
can also be used as an
in-memory data structure store not only
that it can be used as an
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are
a variety of use cases for this redis
cache
and by using redis cache the application
performance is improved
by taking advantage of the low latency
and the height throughput performance
that this redis
cache engine provides so to summarize
this
redis cache when we use redis cache data
is stored
in the memory instead of the disk to
ensure that
there is high throughput and low latency
when the application
needs to read the data it provides
various levels of scaling without any
downtime
or interference now this redis cache is
actually backed by reduce server
and it supports a string hashes
linked list and various other data
structures now let's talk about security
and identity
services now identity management in
specific
is a process of authenticating first and
then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves
controlling information about those
principal identities you might ask now
what's a
principle identity now identity or
principle identity are
services applications users groups
and a lot more the specialty about this
identity management is that
it not only helps authenticate and
authorize
principles in cloud it also helps
authenticate
and authorize principles or resources on
premises
especially when you run and hybrid cloud
environment
so all these services and features that
this identity management
helps us to get additional level of
validation like identity management can
provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide
access policies based on condition a
permit or deny
based on condition it can also monitor
suspicious activity and not only that it
can also report it
it can also help generate alerts for
potential security issues and in a way
to mitigate it
can send us an alert so we can get
involved
and prevent and a security accident
from happening so let's talk more about
identity management
so some of the services under security
and identity
management are azure security center now
this azure security center provides
security management and threat
protection across the workloads
in both cloud and in the hybrid
environment it helps control user access
and application control
to stop any malicious activity if
present
it helps us to find and fix
vulnerabilities before
they can be even exploited it integrates
very well with analytic methods that
helps us to identify or it gives
us the intelligent to identify or deduct
attacks
and prevent them before it can actually
happen and it also works seamlessly with
hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for
on-premises and one policy for
the cloud it's now a unified service
both for on-premises
and the cloud the next service in
security and identity would be
key vault now a key vault is a service
or a feature that helps safeguard the
cryptographic keys and any other secrets
used by the cloud applications and the
services
in other words this azure key vault is a
tool for
securely storing and accessing the
secrets
of the environment i mean the secret
keys now a secret is anything that
you really want to have a very tight
control
access like the certificates like the
passwords
stuff like that now if i tell you what
keyword actually
solves that would actually explain what
keyword is now key vault is used in
secrets management
it's helped in securely storing the
tokens the passwords the certificates
it helps in key management you know it
really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about
certification management it helps us to
easily provision manage and deploy
public and private ssl tls
certificates in azure and lot more so in
a nutshell
this keyword it provides users the
ability to
provision new walls and keys in just a
matter
of minutes all that in a single command
or all that
in a couple of button clicks it also
helps users to centrally manage
their keys secrets and policies
next in the list let's talk about azure
active directory
now azure active directory it helps us
to create
intelligent driven access policies
to limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean
now this azure active directory is a
cloud
based active directory and identity
management service
now azure active directory combines and
it's actually a combination of
the core directory services plus
application access management
plus identity protection and one good
thing about this
azure in fact there are a lot of good
things but especially when you're
running
hybrid environments you might wonder
well how
this azure active directory is going to
behave now this azure active directory
is built to work on on-premises
and cloud environment as well not only
that it also
works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well
so in a nutshell this azure active
directory it acts as an
central point of identity and access
management
for our cloud environment it also
provides
good security solutions that protect
against
unauthorized access of our app and the
data
now that we've discussed about security
and identity
let's talk about the management tools
that azure has to
offer azure provides built-in management
and
account governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep the resources secure
and very compliant and again it helps
both in on premises
and in the cloud environment and these
management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications
it also helps in provisioning and
configuring resources
it also helps in updating apps it helps
in analyzing threats
taking backup of the resources build
disaster
recoveries it also helps in applying
policies and conditions to automate our
environment
we use azure management tools and it's
also used in
cost control methods so this azure
management
plays a wide role across the azure
services and in the management tools
first comes the azure advisor now this
azure advisor it acts
as a guide to educate us about azure
best practices it throws recommendations
that
we can select on the basis of the
category of servers
and it also provides the impact it can
have or
the impact that would happen in our
environment if we
follow the recommendations given and
recommendations or
first one is the recommendations are
kind of templatized
and it throws the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized
recommendations on the basis of the
configuration
on the basis of our usage patterns and
these recommendations are not
hard it's not like something that it
recommends and then
just leaves us hanging there these
recommendations provided
are very easy to follow very easy to
implement and see results you can think
of
as your advisor as an a very
personalized cloud consultant
that helps you to follow best practices
to optimize
our deployments it kind of analyzes our
resources our configurations our usage
and then it recommends a solution for us
that really helps in improving the cost
effectiveness
improving the performance improving high
availability
and improving security in our azure
environment so with this azure advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized
best practice recommendations now you
don't have to be an expert
just follow the azure advisor and your
environment
is going to be good it also helps in
improve the performance security high
availability
of our environment and also it helps in
bringing down the
overall azure spend and the best part is
it's a free service that analyzes our
azure usage and provides recommendations
how we can optimize our azure resource
to reduce cost
and reduce cost at the same time boost
the performance
helps in strengthening the security and
improve the overall
reliability of our environment next in
the list would be network
watcher now this network watcher helps
users
identify and gain insights in the
overall network performance and the
health of
the overall environment now these azure
watchers
provides enough tools to monitor to
diagnose
to view the metrics and to enable or
disable logs
which means regenerate and collect the
logs
for resources in the azure virtual
network so with
network watcher can monitor and diagnose
issues
in networking without even logging into
the virtual machines with
just the logs which are real time we can
actually come to a conclusion what could
be wrong
in a certain resource in a vm or in a
database you know by just looking at the
logs
and not only that it's used for analytic
or to gain
some intelligence of what's happening in
our network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
network
traffic pattern using the security group
flow logs that this network watcher
offers
it also helps in investigating vpn
connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not
know that you know vpn troubleshooting
requires
both parties or it involves two parties
another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on
the other side and they will have to
check logs in their end and we'll have
to check logs and
hour and stuff like that but with the
network
watcher it kind of takes it to the next
level the logs itself
we could easily identify which side is
having
the issue and suggest an appropriate fix
and the next in the list would be
microsoft azure portal
now this microsoft azure portal it
provides a single
unified console to perform various
number of
activities like building not only
building
managing and monitoring the web
applications that
we build now this portal can be used
to organize our environment or the
appearance
of the environment are the visual of the
environment based on our work style
and using azure portal users can control
who gets
to manage or access the resources all
from the azure portal
and this iso portal gives a very good
visibility on
the spends that happen on each resource
right and if we can customize it we can
also identify
spends based on team spends based on
days spends based on department stuff
like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of where
the money is spending or where is the
bill consumed
within the azure environment next in the
list
would be azure resource manager now
azure resource manager
enables us to manage the usage
of the application resources now we use
resource manager to deploy monitor and
manage
solution resources as a group as if
it's one single entity now the
infrastructure of our application is
typically made of
various components which includes
virtual machine
storage virtual network web app
database servers some other third-party
services that we might use in our
environment
and they are by nature separate services
but with azure resource manager we don't
see them as different components or
different entities
instead we see them as related services
in a group that supports an application
now we kind of get the relation between
them instead of you know letting them
spread azure resource manager identifies
the relation
between them and helps us to visually
see them all
as one or single entity not only that
azure resource manager
helps or it ensures that the resources
that we
provision are deployed at a constant
rate along
with the other application it also helps
users to visually see their resources
and
how they are connected and that helps in
managing
the resources lot better resource group
also
is used to control who can access the
resources
within the user's organization kind of
gives you the fine grained control over
who gets to access and
who does not get access and the last one
in
the management tools would be automation
and this automation gives
us the ability to automate configure and
install upgrades across hybrid
environments it provides a cloud-based
automation and configuration
service not only that this can be
applied for non-azure
environments as well which is
on-premises so some of the automation we
could do is
process automation update management
automation
configuration features automation stuff
like that and this azure automation
provides complete
control during the deployment operation
and also during the decommissioning of
the workloads
and resources with automation we can
actually automate
a time consuming or mundane or
any task that's error prone because of
human errors those things can be
automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's going to run the
same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall
time and also the overhead cost because
a lot of the things
are automated which means it's human
error free
which means the application is not going
to break and keep running for a longer
time
with automation we can actually build a
good inventory of operating system
resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease
and this really helps in tracking the
changes and
investigating the issue let's say
something happened because we have
automation
because it's logging the configuration
changes it's easy to track
easy to identify easy to identify what
has changed lately that has
broken the environment go back and fix
it or kind of
roll it back that solves the problem and
that actually summarizes the azure
management tools or management services
now let's talk about the
networking tools or the networking
services available
in azure there are variety of services
especially networking services that
azure offers
and i'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one
let's begin our discussion with content
delivery network now the content
delivery network
in short cdn it allows us to perform
secure and a very reliable content
delivery not only that it also helps in
accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the
delivery time also called as low times
it also helps in
saving bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application
let's expand on this the content
delivery network
is actually a distributed network of
servers that can
efficiently deliver web content to users
now cdns we're going to use the word cdn
here
cdn's store cached content on
global edge servers also called as pops
point of presence locations that are
very close to the
end users so the latency is minimized
it's like taking a copy of the data or
taking a multiple copy of the data and
storing it in
different parts of the world and whoever
is requesting it the data gets delivered
to them
from a server which is very locally to
them
so this cdn offers developers a global
solution for
rapidly delivering high bandwidth
content to users
by caching the content in a
strategically placed
location which is very near to them so
these content delivery networks it
really helps in
handling that's one advantage you get
for content delivery network that's
we can handle spikes and heavy loads
very efficiently
and we can also run analytic against the
logs that gets generated
in content delivery network which helps
in gaining good insight
on the workflow and what would be the
future
business need for that application and
this
just like a lot of other services this
is on a pay as you go
type so you use the results first and
then you only pay for what
you have used the next one in networking
would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit
or a link that provides an a direct
private connection to azure and because
it's direct
it gives low latency link to azure
it gives good speed and reliability for
the azure data transfer it could be on
premises to azure
so it gives very good speed it gives
increased
reliability and low latency for that
connection let's expand on this
a bit now this express route is an
service that
actually provides and private connection
between microsoft data center
and infrastructure in our premises or
in a different co-location facility that
we might have
now these express routes do not go over
the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer
a high security reliability and speed
and low latency compared
to the connections which are in the
internet
because it's fast because it's reliable
because it has
low latency it can be used as an
extension
of our existing data center you know
users are not going to feel
the difference whether they are
accessing services
from an on-premises or in the cloud
environment
because latency is minimized as much as
possible
users are really not going to see the
difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising
a privacy or the performance now these
virtual private cloud these express
routes can be used for
taking backups if assume a backup going
through the internet
that would be a nightmare if you use
express route for backups that's going
to be
fast and imagine recovering a data
through the internet from the cloud
through the internet to the on premises
in a time of disaster that would be the
worst nightmare
so these express routes can be used not
only to backup but also to recover the
data because it provides good speed
low latency recovering the data is going
to be a lot
sooner the next product or service we're
going to discuss
in networking is azure dns now azure dns
allows us to host domain name in azure
and these domain names come with an
exceptional performance
and availability now azure dns
is used to set up and manage dns zones
and records
for our domain name in the cloud now
this azure dns
is a service for dns just like the name
says and
it provides name resolution by using
azure's
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the dns
r cells through the azure portal with
the same credential imagine
having a dns provider which does not
even belong
in rit imagine that environment you know
we would have a separate
portal to manage the dns environment now
those are gone
and now we can actually manage
the dns in the very same azure portal
where we use the rest of the other
services
and this azure dns very much integrates
with other dna service providers
it uses a global network of name servers
to provide
fast response to dns queries
and these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain
service providers availability promises
these are going to have
more availability than the rest because
most of the servers
are maintained by a microsoft and
it helps resolve sooner it helps
re-syncing
let's say a server fails it kind of
helps re-syncing with
the rest of the servers so all the
microsoft's environment
all the microsoft's global network of
name servers kind of ensures that
our domain names are resolved properly
not only properly but also
are available most of the time all right
next in the list
in networking services is virtual
network i'm sure
this is going to be very interesting and
i'm sure you're gonna like it
so this networking or virtual networking
in
azure it actually allows us to set up
our
own private cloud in the public cloud
it gives us an isolated and highly
secure
environment for our application let's
expand on this
then this azure virtual network helps us
to
provision azure virtual machines and
it helps us to securely communicate with
other
on-premises and internet networks
it also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows
through or flows in and out of this
virtual network to other virtual
networks and to the
internet now this azure a virtual
network sometimes called as
v-net is actually a representation of
our own network
in the cloud it's actually a logical
isolation
of the azure cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned
in a v-net that is separate from another
customer's units that way we have that
logical separation there so this virtual
network can also be used to provision
a vpns in the cloud so we can connect
the cloud and the on-premises
infrastructure
and lot more especially in a environment
where we have
hybrid environment surely we will be
using virtual network because
that's going to require a vpn for secure
data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on-premises
environment all right so it kind of
gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic
between the azure resources they kind of
logically
stay in between or logically stay within
the azure virtual network and here we
can
design the network it's given over to us
you know you can pick the ip you can
pick the routing you can pick the subnet
and a lot of freedom is given or i would
say
a lot of control on how the network
is designed it's not like something
that's already cooked and we only get to
use it no
we can actually build the network from
the scratch we can pick
the ip address that we like we can pick
you know which subnet needs to
communicate with the other subnet stuff
like that
and like i said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual network because it
helps
connect the on-premises and the cloud in
a secure fashion
using vpn the last product we're going
to discuss in networking
is a load balancer this load balancer
actually provides
application a good availability and a
good
network performance so how does it work
it actually works by
load balancing the traffic to and from
the virtual machine and the cloud
resources not only that it also
load balances between cloud and
across premises virtual networks with
azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create
high availability for our services which
means
our application will be available most
of the time if any of the server goes
dead
the server does not get traffic what
happens if the server gets traffic user
is going to experience downtime what
happens if the server does not get
traffic user
won't experience any downtime the
connection is shifted to an healthy
service so the user experiences
uptime all the time so this load
balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency
it gives high throughput of the data
transfer
and we can actually scale up the flow of
the tcp and
udp connections from hundreds to
thousands to even
millions because we have a load balancer
now in between the user
and the application so how does it
operate this load balancer actually
receives the traffic
and it load balances the traffic to the
backend pool of instances connected
to it according to the rule and the
health probe that we set
that's how it maintains high
availability so what does load balancer
help it helps in creation of
high available scalable application in
the cloud in minutes
it can be used to automatically scale
the environment with
the increasing application traffic and
one feature of load balancer is to check
the health of the user's
application instance and it removes or
it stops
sending the request to the unhealthy
instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
that's not healthy
that's all that you need to know about
the networking services now let's talk
about
the storage services or the storage
domain
in azure now azure storage in general
is a microsoft manage service
providing cloud storage which basically
is highly available
secure durable scalable and redundant
because
it's all managed by azure we don't get
to manage a lot of it
and these azure storages are a group of
storage services
they cater different needs and the
storage products include azure blobs
which is actually an object storage it
includes
azure data lake it includes azure files
as you see it in it includes azure
queues it includes azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with
azure store simple azure store simple is
an hybrid
cloud storage solution that actually
lowers the cost
of storage to nearly 60 percent of how
much you'd be actually spending without
using it so azure simple storage or
store simple
is an integrated storage solution that
manages
the storage task between on-premises and
the cloud storage what i really like
about azure is that
it's built around a hybrid environment
in mind there are a lot of other cloud
providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know
it has some compatibility you won't be
able to find an
hybrid or a on-premises and cloud
solution for your need
stuff like that but with the azure
especially when it comes to storage a
lot of the things that
we're going to see it clearly is
designed with
hybrid environment in mind all right so
let's come back and talk about
store simple so store simple is an very
efficient cost effective
and a very easily manageable san storage
area networking solution in the cloud i
thought i'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices
which are used in azure data center and
this uh
stores simple or simple storage it comes
along with storage steering
to manage the stored data across the
various
storage media so the current the very
current
data is actually stored in on-premises
on solid-state drives
and data that is used less frequently is
stored in
hdds or hard disk drives and
the data that requires archived or that
needs to be archived very old data let's
say
less frequently used data candidate for
archive
they are actually pushed to the cloud so
you see how this storage sharing
automatically happens in store simple
and
one another cool feature of store simple
is that
it enables us to create an on-demand and
scheduled backups of
data and then store the data locally or
in the cloud and these backups are
actually taken in the form of
incremental
snapshot which means that they can be
created and restored quickly it's not a
complete
backup it's an incremental backup and
these cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important
when there is a disaster and when there
is a disaster recovery scenario because
these snapshots can be called in and
they can be
put on storage systems and then they
become the actual data
so recording is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this
storage simple it really helps in easing
our backup mechanism which means it kind
of eases
our disaster recovery steps or
procedures as well
so this is so simple it can be used to
automate data management data migration
data movement
data turing across the enterprise both
in cloud
and on-premises it actually improves the
compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment
and if there is one thing that's
increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage
and this store simple addresses that
need and we really don't have to
pre-plan
or think in deep or having a proper
storage because
now we have a simple storage available
in the cloud and moreover it's on a
pay-as-you-go type
so not much pre-planning on storage is
needed yes there will be a need but not
as much as i would
without the cloud or without the simple
storage and the next service under
storage that
we would like to discuss is the data
lake store this data lake store
or storage it's a cost effective
solution for
big data analytics in specific so let's
expand this
so this data lake storage is an
enterprise-wide
repository for big data analytic
workload now that's the major service
that's dependent
on this data lake store and this data
lake enables
us to capture data of any size of any
type and
of any injection speed and it kind of
collects them in
one single space or in one single place
for operational efficiency i mean
operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose hadoop in azure
is very dependent on this data lake
storage
and this data lake store is designed
with performance for analytics in mind
so anytime
you think of or anytime you're using
analytic in the cloud or anytime you're
using hadoop
in the cloud in azure we are definitely
using or we will be
to the most part or the normal procedure
or the right storage to pick would be
data lake store in azure it's designed
with security in mind so anytime
we use azure storage we can be rest
assured
that we are using storage from within a
data center
which has or which was built with
security
in mind so this data store also uses
azure blob storage
behind the scenes for global scale
durability
and for performance let's talk about
blob storage
now blob storage provides large amount
of storage and scalability now this blob
storage
is the object storage solution for azure
cloud
let's expand a bit on blob storage azure
blob storage is
microsoft offering for object storage
now this blob storage is optimized for
storing massive amount of unstructured
data which could be
text or binary data it's designed and
it's optimized for
rapid reads if i explain to you on what
scenarios we would be using
blob storage that might help you get a
good understanding of
what blob storage is so it's help or its
design
as of now it's being used in many idea
environments to serve
images or documents directly to the
browser it helps in storing files
for distributed access a lot of features
can fetch data from azure blob storage
and it currently helping users stream
video and audio it's currently being
used for
writing log files it's currently being
used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of disaster
recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage
in a lot of cloud id environments it's
widely used
in storing analytic data not only
storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide
use case for blob storage not only that
in addition to all that we mentioned
it also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates
and data a new version gets created
which means at any point i can
roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility
on optimizing the user's storage
need it also supports tiering of the
data so based on
need when i actually explore i would
find a lot of options
i can pick from that uh you know suits
to my
unique storage environment or unique
storage need
and like i said it stores unstructured
data and this unstructured data is
available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be a queue storage
now queue storage provides durable cues
for large volume cloud services it's a
very simple and a cost effective
durable messaging queue for large
workloads let's expand
this queue storage for a moment now this
q storage is a service for storing large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere
in the world through http and https
calls
a single queue or a single cube message
can be up to like 24 kb in size and
a single queue can contain millions of
such
24 kb in size messages and
how much can it hold it can hold up to
the total capacity
of the storage account itself so that's
kind of easy to translate
how much would it hold and this azure
queue storage it provides an
messaging solution between applications
and components in the cloud what does it
help it helps in
designing an application for scale it
helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent
or sometimes it's not at all dependent
on the other application because
now we have a q in between which kind of
translates
or which kind of connects or which kind
of decouples
both the environment now we have a queue
in between
both the environment can scale up or
scale down independently
the next in the storage service would be
file storage
let's talk about file storage now these
azure files provide
secure simple and managed cloud
file shares now with file share in the
cloud it actually extends the user
servers
on-premises performance and capacity and
a lot of familiar tools for
the cloud file share management can be
used along with
the file storage that we're talking
about so let's expand
a bit on file storage now this azure
files or azure file storage offers
a fully managed file shares in the cloud
that can be accessed
via the smb protocol server
message block protocol now this azure
file shares
can be mounted concurrently by cloud
or in on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems
are compatible with it windows are
compatible linux is compatible
mac os is compatible in addition to
all this being able to run on
on-premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on-premises and on
the cloud
it can also offer cash for caching the
data and keeping it locally
so it's immediately available when
needed so that's some additional feature
i would say that some advanced feature
that it offers
compared to the other file shares
available in the market
let's talk about table storage let's
talk about table storage now table
storage is a
no sql key value pair storage for
quick deployments with the large
semi-structured data sets
the difference between one important
thing to note with table storage
is that it has a flexible data schema
and also it's highly available let's
expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less
a nosql type table storage is the one
we'll end up picking it provides an key
pair
attribute storage with a schema-less
design
this table storage is very fast and very
cost effective
for many of the applications and for the
same
amount of data it's a lot cheaper when
you compare
it with the traditional sql data or data
storage
so some of the things that we can store
in the table storage are
of course they're going to be flexible
data sheets
such as user data for web application
address books device information and
other types of
metadata for our service requirements
and it can have any number of
tables up to the capacity limit of the
storage account now this
is not possible with sql this is only
possible with nosql especially with
table storage in azure explanation of
storage
really concluded the length and breadth
of the explanation
this ceo was giving his id
personal but this id personal is not
done
with it yet he still has a question even
after this lengthy discussion and his
question was
well there are a lot of other cloud
providers available what
made you specifically choose azure i
mean
from the kind of question that he asked
we can say that he is very curious
and he definitely had asked and very
thoughtful question so his
ceo went on and started to explain about
the uh other capabilities of azure or
how it kind of outruns the rest of the
cloud providers so he started or
he again started his discussion but from
a different angle now so he started to
explain
what are the capabilities or how azure
is better than
the competitors so he started with
explaining the
platform as a service capabilities and
i'm going to tell you what the ceo
told his id person so this platform as a
service
or in platform as a service the
infrastructure management is
completely taken care by microsoft
allowing users to focus completely on
the innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities
go and focus on innovation that's that's
a fancy way of saying it when we buy
platform as a service
that's what we get we can contribute our
time on innovation and not
just maintaining the infrastructure and
azure
especially is uh dotnet friendly azure
supports the.net programming language
and it has or it is built or designed or
it is
optimized to work with old and the new
applications deployed
using dotnet programming framework so if
your
application is a dark net most of the
time
you would end up picking azure i mean if
you try to compare
most of the time you would end up
picking azure as your cloud service
provider and the security offerings that
azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development uh
life cycle which is an industry leading
assurance
process when we buy services from azure
it assures that the environment is
designed
based on security development
life cycle and like i mentioned many
times
in the past and i would like to mention
it again azure
has well thought about the hybrid
environments
which a lot of other cloud providers
have failed
so it's very easy to set up and hybrid
environment to migrate the data or not
to migrate the data and still
run a hybrid environment they work
seamlessly
with azure because azure provides
seamless connection across on-premises
data centers
and the public cloud it also has a very
gentle
learning curve if you look at the
documentation it's
picture rich and the documentations are
neat and clear would
really it would encourage you to learn
more it would encourage you to
think and imagine and try easily get a
grasp of
how services work so it has a very
gentle learning curve
azure allows the utilization of
technologies that
several businesses have used for years
so there is a big history behind it
it has a very gentle learning curve the
certifications the documentations
the stage by stage certification levels
it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing
in other cloud service providers now
this would
really impress the ctos or people
working in
finance and budgeting if an organization
is already using microsoft software
they can definitely go and avail or be
bold and ask for
a discount that can reduce the overall
azure
spending in other words overall a
pricing of the azure
so that's what helped or they are the
information that
helped the ceo pick azure as his
cloud service provider and then the ceo
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently
using azure and they are definitely
using azure for a reason like
pixar boeing samsung easyjet
xerox bmw 3m they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely
run operate their i.t in azure
and this ceo has a thought that his i.t
person is still not
very convinced unless and until he shows
him
a visual of how easy things are in azure
so he goes on and explains about
a practical application of azure
which is what exactly i'm going to show
you as well alright a quick
project on building an azure app
using or building a dotnet application
in azure web app and making it connect
to
an sql database will solidify all the
knowledge that
we have gained so far so this is what
we're gonna do
i have an azure account open as you see
logged in
and everything is fresh here let me go
to resource group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right i'm logged in
and this is what we're gonna do so we're
gonna create an
application like this which is nothing
but an
to-do application to do list application
we're just gonna run from the web app
get information from us
and save it in the database that's
connected to it so you can already see
it's a
two-tiered application web and db
all right so let me go back to my azure
account the first thing is to create an
resource
group let's give it an a meaningful name
let's call it azure simply learn all
right
and it's going to be a free trial and
the location
pick one that's nearest to you or
you know wherever you want to launch
your application now
for this use case i'm going to pick
central us and
create it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called azure simply
learn now what do we need we need an web
app
and and a separate sql database
let's first get our web app running so
go to app services
and then click on add it's not the web
app plus sql that we want we want
web app alone for this example so let's
create and web app
uh give it a quick name let's call it
azure
simply learn the subscription is free
trial
and i'm going to use my existing
resource group a resource group that we
created some time back
it's going to run out of windows and
we're going to publish
the code all set we can create it all
right while this is running
let me create my database
right sql database create a database
give it a name let's call it azure
simply learn db
put it in our existing resource group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some
settings like the name of the server
and the admin login the password that
goes along
and in which location this is going to
be created the server name is going to
be
azure simply learn db that's the server
name
and the admin login can be
what can be the admin login name let's
see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an
web app and we have created an a
database
in the resource group that we have
created so if i go to resource group
it's going to take some time before
things show up so if i
go to my resource group i only have one
resource group as of now
azure simply learn and there i have a
bunch of resources
being created and it's still being
created
right in the meantime i have my
application
right here that's running out of or
that's
in visual studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the azure
console we're gonna go back to visual
studio
feed these inputs in the visual studio
so
the code knows what the database is the
the credentials to log into the database
stuff like that so we're going to feed
those information
in visual studio by that we're actually
feeding it into the application and then
we're going to run it from there
deploying this application
takes quite a while we really got to be
patient
right now we have all the resources that
we need
for the application to run here's my
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is
create and firewall exception rule so
one more thing
needed is to create and firewall
exception
rule right so the application is going
to run from my
local desktop and it's going to connect
to the
database right so let's add an exception
rule
by simply adding the client id it's
going to pick my ip
the ipf laptop i'm using as of now and
it's going to create an exception
to access the database so that's done
now we can go back to our visual studio
i already have a couple of apps running
or a couple of
configurations pushed from visual studio
i'm going to clean that up
if you're doing it for the first time
you you may not need to do this
all right so let's start from the
scratch this is
very similar to how you would be doing
in your environment all right so we're
going to select an existing
azure app service now before that i have
logged in
as you can see i have logged in with my
credentials so it's going to pull few
things automatically
from my azure account so in this case
i'm
gonna use an existing azure app so
select
existing and then click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very
same resources that we created a while
back
all right we have clicked on save and
it's running kind of validating
the code and it's going to come up with
an
url now initially the url is
not going to work because we haven't
mapped
the application to the database that
would be the next thing
all right so the app has been published
and it's running from my
web app as of now it's going to throw an
error like you see it's throwing an
error that's
because we haven't mapped the app
and the db together so let's do that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server explorer
this is where we're going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to the resource group
all right appropriate resource group
which is right here
and here i have my database
azure simply learn database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my
database give me a quick moment let's
fix it
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application
all right so let's go to the solution
explorer
click on publish and
a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our a web app all right with all
its
credentials let's validate the
connection
number one all right and then
click on next this is my
db connection string right which the app
is going to use
to connect to my db now if you recall
rdb
was a azure simply learn db and that's
not being
shown here so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure and here
let's put our db servers
url now before that let's change this to
sql server all right and then in here
put the db's url so go back to azure
here is my db or
server's name put that here
right the username to connect to the
server that's
right here put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect to our
azure
portal or the azure infrastructure and
here is my
database if you recall it's azure sldb
that's the name of the database
let's test the connection connection is
good
click on ok
so now it's showing up correctly azure
simply learn
db that's the name of the database
that'll be created now it's configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again all right
so our name of the database is azure
simply learn db
and then it's going to be
sql server that's the data source
the username is
simply learn and the password is
what we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate the connection
it's good click ok
now we're all set and ready to publish
our application again now the
application knows how to connect
to the database we have educated it with
the the correct connection strings the
dns name
the username and the password for the
application
to connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an url
to connect and anytime
we put or we give inputs to the url
that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and
i can start creating to-do lists for
myself all right so i have items already
listed
i can create an entry and these entries
get stored
in the in the database i can create
another entry
you know take the dock for a walk that's
going to get
stored i can create another entry uh
book tickets for scientific
exhibition and that's going to receive
and
put that in the database and that
concludes
our session so through this session we
saw how i can use
azure services to create a web app and
connect that to the db instance and how
those two services which are decoupled
by default which are separate by default
how i can
you know use the connection strings to
make connection between the app server
and the database and be able to create
an
working app i strongly believe you
enjoyed me walking you through this
session
i'd like to welcome all of you to this
training video on azure
so here we have two friends having a
conversation with each other
one of them says that her company is
moving all of its physical data
and migrating it onto the cloud she says
that they're using a cloud service
provider known as azure
now here's the problem she doesn't
really understand how cloud service
providers work or even how the cloud
does
her friend decides to help her out so in
this video
here's what we're going to talk about
first we'll talk about what is cloud
computing
what is microsoft azure what are the
services that azure offers
and then we'll have a look at a use case
where we'll be applying one of these
services to get a particular job done
now for the first question what is cloud
computing
so cloud computing actually provides a
platform through which you can access
resources
now these resources include servers
storage application security
and other ways you can transform your
data or get some use out of it
now at the same time you can also store
manage and process your data
now anything related to cloud computing
is made possible only with the help
of the internet now along with these
things there are several other things
that you can do
with cloud computing now let's have a
look at some of the ways cloud computing
is making our lives better
firstly you have services for just about
every requirement that you have
then you get access to the newest and
most innovative technologies in the
market right now
cloud computing provides cost-effective
solutions with flexible pricing
now most cloud service providers work in
such a way that you only pay for the
amount of time you use that particular
resource then you have one of the most
important selling points when it comes
to cloud computing which is that data
and applications are accessible from any
part of the world
as long as you have access to the
internet and finally you have
increased protection for your data and
applications
now you should know that there are
several cloud service providers in the
market right now
be it amazon web services adobe creative
cloud
google cloud platform and so much more
now among all these platforms
there's one that's growing really really
fast and that is microsoft azure
now let's ask the question what is
microsoft azure
microsoft azure is actually a cloud
service platform that allows users to
build
manage scale and deploy applications by
giving them access to cloud
services now these cloud services range
from creating virtual machines
to creating functions that run
themselves without having to worry about
hardware
now all of this is made possible only
through the internet
now here are some things that you need
to know about azure firstly it was
launched on the first of february 2010
it has data centers in more than 42
regions across the world
they also say that 12 more data centers
are in the making which helps them say
they're the only cloud service provider
that covers these many regions
next azure is preferred by 80 of the
fortune 500 companies which means that
the best of the best in the market
only choose to work with us europe and
finally azure is the second largest
cloud service provider in the market
right now
let's talk about azure services as i
told you azure provides services for a
wide range of domains
now let's have a look at some of these
domains there's ai and machine learning
compute containers database identity
management tools networking security
storage and so much more now let's have
a look at some of the individual
services within these domains
firstly you have azure virtual machines
with azure virtual machines what you get
is the opportunity to create windows or
linux virtual machines
now all of this is possible in a matter
of seconds with a large amount of
customization
now let's have a look at some of its
features firstly you can choose from a
wide variety of virtual machine options
then you have a large amount of
optimization available to you for
example
what size of operating system do you
want how much size do you want allocated
to it
what version of the system is it and so
much more
then it provides low cost and permanent
billing now azure provides you permanent
billing which means
that you're only charged for how much
time you use the service
and finally you have enhanced security
and protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have a platform
which enables you to create micro
services now this also makes the process
of application lifecycle management a
whole lot
easier as a direct result you can create
applications with a faster time to
market
it supports windows linux on-premises or
other clouds
and it enables you to do a tremendous
amount of scaling
up depending on your requirement and
finally we have functions
now with functions you can build
applications with the help of serverless
computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used
you can create applications in any
language that you want
and the only thing you need to worry
about is the code of the application
everything other than that that is the
hardware requirements are taken care of
by azure
now let's have a look at the networking
services firstly we have the azure cdn
or the content delivery network with
azure cdn what you get
is the ability to deliver your content
with reduced load times
fast responsiveness and less bandwidth
now cdn can be integrated with
several other azure services so that the
process can move at a faster rate
it can handle heavy loads and traffic
spikes with ease
it also provides a robust security
system now with the content that's
delivered you can get advanced analytic
data
with which you can understand how
customers are using your content
next we have express route with express
route you can connect
your on-premises network to azure
through a private network
now by default this lowers latency it
increases the emphasis on
reliability and speed and it can be of
great use when you have to transfer
large amounts of data between networks
now another way this can be useful
is if it's used to add compute or
storage capacity
to data centers next we have azure dns
domain name service or azure dns can be
used to host your domains
on azure this provides high availability
and
great performance it provides fast
responses to dns queries by taking
advantage of microsoft's global network
it also provides high availability next
we have virtual network
azure virtual network allows the azure
resources to communicate with each other
or
other on-premise networks via the
internet and all of this
is kept extremely secure now with this
users can create their own
private network for communication it
provides users with an isolated
and extremely secure environment for
their applications to run
now all of the traffic stays entirely
within the azure network
and it also allows users to design their
own networks
next we have traffic manager now with
traffic manager you can route
incoming traffic to improve your
performance and availability
now one thing it provides is multiple
failover options
so if a particular situation goes wrong
there's always an
option to consider to salvage the
situation it helps reduce application
run time
and enables the distribution of user
traffic across multiple locations
it also helps the people who are using
it to know where the customers
connecting from across the world next we
have load balancer
with this you are provided the ability
to instantly scale applications
at the same time providing high
availability and improved network
performance for users applications it
can be integrated into virtual machines
and cloud services
it provides highly reliable applications
it also allows users to secure
and integrate security groups finally we
have
azure vpn gateway now this allows users
to connect their
on-premise networks to azure using a
site-to-site vpn
now this allows users to connect their
virtual machine to anywhere in the world
through a point-to-site vpn and also
it's very easy to manage
and is highly available now let's talk
about the storage services
first we have data lake storage now with
this what you get is a scalable data
storage with an emphasis
on cost effectiveness and scalability
now
it comes of maximum use when you
integrate it with other services
so that you can get analytics on how the
data is being used
it is also integrated with other
services like the azure blob storage
now it is also optimized for big data
analysis tools like apache spark
and hadoop next up we have blob storage
now blob storage provides a storage
capacity for data
now depending on how often a particular
data is used it is classified into
different tiers
now all the data that is within the blob
storage is unstructured data
now it has a way of ensuring that the
data integrity is maintained
every time a particular object is being
changed or the data is being accessed
and it also helps improve app
performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption
next we have queue storage now with this
you have a message
queuing system for large workloads this
allows users to build flexible
applications
and separate functions not to mention
with this you can be sure that your
individual components will not fail
it also makes sure that your application
is scalable
queue storage provides queue monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer's
demands are met
then we have file stored now with file
storage you can perform
file sharing with the help of the smb
protocol or the server message block
protocol
now this data is protected by smb 3.0
and the https protocol in this case like
we mentioned in functions
azure takes care of all the hardware
needs and the operating system
deployments
on its own it also improves on-premises
performance and other capabilities
lastly we have table storage with table
storage you can deploy
semi-structured data sets and nosql key
value store
now this is used for creating
applications which have a flexible data
schema
and also considering how it has a very
strong consistency model
it's mainly aimed for enterprises next
let's have a look at some
web and mobile services first we have
the azure search
now with azure search you get a cloud
search service which is powered by
artificial intelligence
with this you can develop web
applications as well as mobile
applications
now one big advantage is that you don't
have to set up
or manage your search indices azure
takes care of that
and by extension it increases your
development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search
and structured information next we have
logic apps
now with this you can create integration
solutions which can connect
applications that are important to your
business now with this
you can visually create business
processes and workflows
you can integrate sas or software as a
service applications and enterprise
applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data
within a firewall and securely connect
to services
next we have web applications now with
web apps you can create
deploy and scale web applications
according to business requirements
now it supports both windows and linux
platforms
and it helps with continuous integration
or deployment abilities
another very important aspect of this is
that the data can be deployed
and hosted across multiple locations in
the world and finally we have mobile
apps
with mobile apps you can create
applications for ios
android and windows platforms one
advantage is that it
automatically scales up and down based
on your requirements
now in situations where you have network
issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create
cross-platform applications or native
applications for
ios android and windows next
let's have a look at some container
services first let's talk about
acs or azure container services it is
also known as the azure kubernetes
services
as it's a fully managed kubernetes
container orchestration service
now what this means is that it eases the
process of container integration and
deployment
it also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your
container is kept secure next we have
container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers
now applications can be developed here
without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is azure's problem to take care of
and it enables building applications
without having to manage the
infrastructure
that is all you need to worry about is
running the container
next let's have a look at some database
services first we have the sql database
now with sql database what you get is a
relational cloud database service
now this means that it helps accelerate
your app development
and makes it easier for you to maintain
your application
nosql database is also used extensively
in migrating workloads to the cloud
and hence saves time and cost it also
helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and adaptive
technologies into your database
next we have azure cosmos db now this is
a globally distributed multi-model
database
service now what this means is that with
this
you can create application with support
nosql
it provides a high grade security system
has high availability
and low latency now this is usually used
in situations where you have a diverse
and highly unpredictable workload now
let's have a look at some security and
identity services
firstly we have the azure active
directory now if you want to know more
about azure active directory i suggest
you click on the top right corner and
watch our video
on the azure active directory this is
just an introduction
so with this you can manage user
identities
and you can make sure the resources are
kept safe with the help of access
policies most of these are intelligence
driven
now one of the main features is that you
can have access to your applications
from any location or device
it helps increase your efficiency and
helps down cutting costs when it comes
to having
a help desk it can also help improve
security
and can respond to advanced threats in
real time
next you have azure active directory b2c
it helps provide customer identity and
access management in the cloud
now protecting customer identity is
extremely important
for an organization and that's what
azure adb2c does
now it also enables the application to
be scaled to
great amounts even billions of customers
next we have the azure security center
this is basically like a command post
with which you get a complete
view of the security across users on
your on-premises and cloud workloads
so with this you are given threat
protection method that adapts
to situations and helps reduce exposing
you to threats
it also has rapid threat response and
makes the process of finding and fixing
vulnerabilities a whole lot
easier next up let's talk about
monitoring and management services
so first let's have a look at azure
advisor now azir advisor is basically
a guide for the best practices when it
comes to azure
now when you follow these it improves
performance security
cost and increases availability now it
also
learns from how you use the services on
your configuration
and usage pattern and the adjustments
that it suggests
can be implemented very quickly and
easily next we have network watcher now
with this you can monitor
diagnose and understand the working of
your network
now you can monitor your network without
actually having to log in to your
virtual machine
now you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern
how much traffic is coming towards you
how much you're giving and so much more
it also helps diagnose vpn problems that
you might have
with detailed logs and finally you have
the azure resource manager
now with this you can ensure that the
resources that you have
are managed and deployed at a consistent
rate
now this makes it extremely easy for you
to manage and visualize your resources
that are used in your applications or
some other requirements
and you can control who can access your
resources
as well as perform actions on it and now
let's have a look at how we can use one
of these services
to satisfy a particular requirement so
the friend asks that she needs one
last bit of help she wants her friend's
help to host the website on his yaw and
here's how we can do it
so now we're going to put one of these
services into action
so this is the azure dashboard so from
here
we are going to create a virtual machine
within which we are going to create a
website
a very simple html website nonetheless
so let's get started so first what we're
going to do
is create a resource a resource group so
what a resource group is is actually a
repository of all the resources
like virtual machines or storage that
you're going to use
in your project so in this we need a
virtual machine so let's get that
created so first we'll name it
demo east us and we'll create it
now this will take a few seconds and
that's it
so now that that's done we go on add
so we're going to be using a windows
operating system so we'll just search
for virtual machine
we select this and create
okay so here we are going to set up
we're going to select the resource group
the one just
that we just created a virtual machine
name
okay this
storage name
passwords and then
just breeze through the rest of it we
can
reduce the size we need this big
and create
now that the validation is done the next
step is to
create now this will take a few minutes
so we'll wait and as you can see here
the virtual machine has been created
we'll go to the source
so here all we need to do is connect and
download the rdp file
let's see if we run this file and see
what happens
now this error shows up in a whole lot
of systems that i've used
so this is a very easy way to
troubleshoot this problem so
here's what you need to do no so these
are the problems as remote access to the
server is not enabled the remote
computer is turned off
the remote computer is not available on
the network so what we're going to do
is go to networking and add an inbound
port rule
now we're trying to access a computer
remotely right
so to remotely access the computer we
would need to add an inbound port rule
so that's what we're going to do right
now so we can keep the source as any
port ranges any and our destination port
as
3389 if you've noticed there we'd
actually have
used the 3389 as the inbound port and
then
we change the name as 3389 and
this rule is added now after this is
done
all we need to do you can see here that
we refresh the page
this would be here
a new rule has been added now so we'll
go to overview
and try to connect again do the same
thing again
and this time it worked so here we'll
input the name
and our password
and that's it now we just press yes
and there you go the system has started
now your virtual machine is started now
in a while the server manager will pop
up
so there's some things that we need to
do so that we can host the website
so the first thing is to create an
inbound port so we'll turn off the
virtual machine for now
come back to that later first we'll go
to
a resource group check the name of our
resource and then we look at
all its resources here so here we need
to find
at the network security group and add
an inbound security rule press add
we take any source any source port range
and then we add port 80 which is the one
that we're going to use and we'll put
the name as port
80. we'll add the security rule
which will take a few seconds
and that's that now it's a lot now let's
go back to our virtual machine
here you go and let's get it started
log in again
and there you have it it's on again now
we'll go to server manager
so we need to add roles and features so
most of this we can just
run through we'll leave them at the
default values
same and here we need to add a web
server which is the iis
so we'll select this
we add the features next so we can add
the dotnet
3.5 features as well next
and we'll install now
now we'll wait for the installation to
finish and now the installation is done
so now what we're going to see is if the
website can be reached
i will go to the public address which is
given here so we've come back to our
original system click
and you can see that the is page has
been created
now we need to work more to create the
html page
here's what we'll need to do to run our
website so right now what we're getting
is this
the is page now let's make it our own
html page a very simple html page from
there on we can create the website
so go back to the virtual machine and
then we go to
c drive so the is
is located in a location which is in c
drive
init pub and www root
so if you click on this actually what
you'll get is the page i showed you
earlier which is
this one so now we'll go to the server
manager
click on tools and find the
iis manager
so we click on this
and sites now there is a default website
we can now add a new one
site name
demo we need a physical path
we'll put it inside the folder we just
saw which is
right here c drive unit pub
wwe root within which we'll create a new
folder
for simply on demo
we save it and put 80
and okay now this is assigned to another
site so we'll change that
but we'll wait for that okay
now for this we'll just change it we
click on this
so since both of them have the same port
we'll change that go here
edit binding we change this
to something else
okay and close so now both are different
and now we can start our website
it's already started now
now we'll start the website right click
this
manage website and start
and that's it now we will go to the
to the internet pub wwe root and we have
simply learn demo
so here we will create the html website
or the html
the document so
index.html okay
open this
it's a very simple website now so we
keep it
save it
so here what we're going to do is save
as
an html file but for all
all files
we close this now to make sure this is
recognized as a dot html file
it go to view options
here we'll hide extensions for known
file types
just rename this
[Music]
and there you have it it's a dot html
file
now let's go back to our original
computer
and run this page and there you have it
now this is just the initial version
more work has to be done on it but your
first step is already done
and today we will be talking about
machine learning in azure
before we move on let me tell you what
azure is so azure is microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it
provides you with various services
like compute analytics networking and
storage
so you can pick from these services to
develop and scale your applications
or run existing applications in the
public cloud
okay so once you log into azure portal
and select machine learning as your
service you will be redirected to this
page now on the right hand side you can
see there's an option called my
workspace
so once you click on my workspace it
will take you to a new window which is
machine learning studio but before that
let me give you a small idea of what my
workspace is
so any data that we get into our machine
learning studio
we analyze it and that is presented
under my workspace
now on the left hand side you can see
there are few options under machine
learning studio page
so let me go through those options one
so the first option is
projects so project basically gives you
a list of all the experiments that we
have worked on
then comes experiments so experiments
are
all the programs that you work on to
create a model
after that it's web services so since
azure is a cloud computing platform we
know that all the data needs to be
uploaded over the cloud
by data i mean all the experiments that
we have needs to be uploaded over the
cloud
so web services gives you a list of all
the experiments that we have
and is over the cloud so that you can
access it from anywhere
then comes notebooks so notebooks are
basically space where you can explore
analytics
you can create your own code you can
visualize it and at the last you can
share it with your peers
then it's data sets so the data set
gives you a list of all the data set
that you have in your azure portal now
when you click on sample these are all
the sample data set that azure has
provided
as to the users now comes trained models
so while working in an experiment you'll
come to a point where you need to train
your model
so this gives you a list of all the
models that you have trained in your
azure program then at the last you have
settings
so any changes that you make is done
under settings so now that
we are done with this let's go to the
next half of our azure tutorial
so on the left hand side you can see
there's an option called new when you
click on new it will open a window so
this window gives you a list of all the
templates that we have in our azure
machine
learning studio okay so since we are
working from the scratch
we will be working on blank experiment
so once you click on blank experiment a
new window appears
okay so let me go through the component
that we have here so on the left hand
side you have the components
at the center you have the canvas where
your experiments will take place
and on the right hand side you have
properties so today we'll be working on
problem statement which says that we
need to find out the income
of an individual whose data we don't
have in our system
now let's go on to the component part
and find the best data set that can suit
our problem statement
okay so we see that we have list of data
sets in our samples
so the very first data set it adopts
senses income binary classification
so we've selected data set and drag it
over to the canvas
but before that let me give a name to
our experiment so we'll give the name as
income prediction
now once you click on adult census
income you can see there is a circle
press right click and four options
appears in front of you
the first one is download the second is
visualized
third is generate access code and the
last one is notebook
since we need to visualize the data set
we will click on visualize
so once you click on visualize a new
window appears
on the left hand side you can see there
are 32 000 nodes and 15 columns that we
have in our data set
but before that let me go through all
the columns that we have here
so the first one is age which gives you
a which tells about the age of a person
then is work class so this gives you an
idea whether he's a government employee
is he working in a private sector or is
he a self-employed then is fnlwgt which
is the sample weight of the field
then is the education so education is
basically telling us about his
highest degree whether is it bachelor's
is it high school grad
or is he a master's then comes education
number
so this gives you an idea of the number
of years he took to complete his
education
then is marital status so this is
telling about a person's
is he married or whether he has never
married then is occupation
so occupation is actually important
while finding out the
income so if a person is a manager there
a chance he will be earning more as
compared to others
then his relationship whether he is a
husband is she a wife or has he never
married
then comes sex whether he is a male or
the female then his capital gain capital
loss
hours per week so this gives you an idea
of number of hours a person is working
in a week then is native country so
income varies from country to country so
getting to know about the country is
also very important while detecting our
model and at the last we have income
we see that the income column is divided
into two halves which is
above 50 and below 50. so there are two
distinct values in income group and in
cases like these we make use of
classification algorithm
now let's go to the next part which is
where we will define
the fields that we need to have for our
prediction
so what we do here is we select the
column so on the search bar when you
type column under manipulation you get a
list of
options from that you select column in
dataset and drag it over to the canvas
now connect your data set with select
column in data set now
under this you can see there's a caution
which says that value required
so you go under properties and select
launch column selector
so once you select launch column
selector window appears
so this gives you a list of all the
columns that we have in our data set
so the very first column that we have
here is age so age is actually important
in understanding the income of a person
then comes work class so the background
of a person whether he's working in a
government employee or is he a private
employee
is also important for prediction of
income then comes education
a person who has a master's degree has
more chances of earning than a person
who
has a graduation degree so education is
also an important field while predicting
our income
then what comes next is occupation after
that you have
country and at the last we will work on
incur
now when you press next you get back to
the same window
so now that we know the fields that
we're working on our next step is to
find the algorithm that best suits our
model okay so now that we know the
fields that we have to work on our next
step is to find the best fit algorithm
for our model
so what we do here is we look at the
list of algorithms that we have but
before that we know that our data
our target value is divided into two
classes so the algorithm that we'll be
working on
is a classification algorithm now azure
provides few
classification algorithm like logistic
and decision tree two class
booster decision tree so we'll be
working on two class boosted decision
tree because
this gives you a high accuracy rate now
let me give you an idea of
why two class boosted decision tree is
taken over all the other classification
algorithm
so what happens in 2 class booster
decision tree is for every node
that we have here the accuracy is
calculated and once the accuracy is
above our required accuracy then only it
moves on to the next
nodes so this gives you a height so the
prediction value
here becomes more and more towards the
higher side
so that the overall model will give us a
very high accuracy
okay so our next step here is to train
the model so on the search bar again
just type train and under train you can
see there's an option called train model
so drag the train model over the canvas
and connect the two cloud boosted
decision tree with this now you can see
that it says that it requires a value
or a data which is obvious because it's
not it does not have any data
to work on so our next step here is to
split the data
so on the search bar when you find split
it gives you an option called split data
when you drag the split data over your
canvas
and connect it with your column data it
asks you for the split percentage
so you split the data into training and
testing
so eighty percent of data gets into the
training model and twenty percent goes
into the testing model
so what we do next is we connect eighty
80 of training data
with the train model but you see there
is a value required
this is because the model is not aware
of the column it needs to train on so
what we do here is
we go on launch column selector
and select the column so we need to work
on income column
so when we select column and press enter
we see that the
question mark is gone now our next step
is to
find the score of the model so what
score does is
it gives you the prediction value of the
model
okay so when you connect your trade
model with the score model you again see
a caution sign here
this is because it does not have idea of
what it needs to test on so you collect
your testing data with your score model
our last step here is to evaluate the
model so on the search bar when you type
evaluate
you get an option called evaluate model
you drag the model
here on the canvas and connect it with
the score model
so your model is now complete now our
next step is to save the model
and run it
now once our program is executed click
on evaluate model once you click on
evaluate model and press visualize
a window will appear this shows you the
performance of the model
you see that the accuracy is 79 which is
considered to be good
now let me go through all the other
options you see there is an option
called positive label and negative level
which has been assigned values of above
50k and below 50 kids respectively
now let me tell you what these values
are so this part is known as a confusion
matrix
so of all the values above 50k true
positive give me value that are
predicted correctly
and false positive give me value that
are not predicted correctly
which means that six out of all the
value that we have in
positive label 666 667
have been predicted right that is they
have their salary above 50k
and 422 have been predicted wrong
similarly
they're out of all the people that we
have 840
have been predicted wrongly that if they
have salary of above 50k
but have been predicted below 50k and
4091 have been predicted correctly
now this is used to find the accuracy of
the model so what you do here is you sum
the true positive with true negative
and divided by false positive false
negative true positive and too negative
and then you multiply it 100 and that's
how you get your accuracy
now let us go back and run this service
over the net
so when you click on setup web service
you see predictive experiments
click on predictive experiment
now our next step is to connect a web
service input that is the entry point
with the score model so what it does is
once the program is over the cloud it
directly connects to the score model
and shows us the output so you don't
have to go through all the processes
now because the machine is automatically
learning
now you save this and press run this
will execute the entire model
so once this is done all that is left
with you is to
deploy a web service so once you click
on deploy web service
it will take you to the dashboard
so you see an option called test once
you click on test
it will take you to a window where it
will ask you for values
so let's just say that i have a value of
person age 35
let's say he's working in a government
his education is
bachelor's then his occupation is
manager
this country is us so once i press
next it will give me the predicted value
telling me that he will be earning 50k
with the precision rate of 0.12
so this is how you make use of machine
learning in azure we are going to talk
about the service
as your active directory so firstly
let's ask the most important question
what is azure active directory now here
we're in a situation where we have two
colleagues having a conversation with
each other
so one of them complains that he is
finding a hard time managing multiple
user logins at the same time
his friend suggests that he has a
solution that the company start using
as your active directory he says that
with azure ad
they'll be able to handle multiple user
logins without any issue
so just like the question in all our
minds the friend asks how is azure
active directory going to help us so to
help you understand
let's think about a scenario you're an
employee working for an organization
and you want to use a particular service
in this case sql database
so you're assigned a set of username and
password then you want to use another
service
a machine learning service again you're
assigned a different username and
password
and likewise for any number of services
that you want to use
so for every service that you're going
to choose you need to be assigned a new
username and password
but this becomes a huge issue for the
administrator as they have to handle
a large number of username and passwords
now if you think about a large
organization where there's more than
thousand people working
you can understand how much of a hassle
it's going to be for the administrator
at the same time it's also a really
difficult thing for you to remember
that many numbers of username and
passwords it's difficult on the user as
well
and that's where azure active directory
helps now here's a scenario where we're
applying azure active directory
now you're an employee you want to use a
particular service and you're assigned
a single username and password and with
this username and password you can
access
all the services that you want so
there's only one set of username and
passwords that you need to remember
you can use any of the services that you
want as long as the administrator has
given you access to it
so what is azure active directory now
azure active directory is a service that
falls under the identity domain
it allows multiple users and is a
cloud-based
directory and identity management
service now here's an ideal scenario
you're joining an office newly the admin
helps you
sign up to whatever services you want
and you can access these services
anywhere over the cloud so now let's
talk about something different
windows 80 and azure ad now windows 80
was the previous version
of azure 80. so now we'll talk about why
we needed to change from windows active
directory
to azure active directory so what is
windows active directory
now it's an os directory service which
allows you to work with
multiple systems multiple network
resources in a unified manner
now the biggest draw when it came to
windows 80 was that it had
many layers now different layers that
did different bits of work
so now let's talk about each of these
layers the first layer
is ads or the windows active directory
domain services
now each layer as i said before has a
different role to perform
adds allows admin to manage information
relating to user logins
and other details like when they signed
up how much they're using and things
like that
the next layer is adls or the azure data
leak storage services this
layer is for allowing you to store any
amounts of data
of any type or size then you have the
adfs or the active directory
federation services where you're given a
single option for sign up
with which you get access to all systems
and applications
then we have the fourth layer the adcs
or the active directory and
certification services
this enables administrators to customize
services
and then be able to manage and issue
public certificates
and the final layer is adrms or the
active directory rights management
service
and this is used for data protection now
here's where azure active directory
changed the whole game this means that
there's a large number of layers that
administrators need to take care of now
how about there was a solution for this
and as your ad is that solution as your
active directory
integrates all these five layers into
two and these are
the windows azure active directory or
the wad
where it combines all the problems when
it comes to identification management
which is
almost all file layers taken into one
and the windows as your access control
service
enables the federation or the division
of all these services
of an organization and by division i
mean assigning each of these services
to these users so that is taken care of
by the windows as your access control
service
hence as your active directory is able
to simplify a lot of the problems that
windows as azure active directory had
for example the application office 365
uses as your active directory to manage
user identities
here's how now you're an employee who
wants to access one of the office 365
services which could be
excel powerpoint microsoft word or
something like that
so you go talk to the administrator and
he gives you
access to these services with the help
of a single username
and password now as long as you have
this username and password and the
administrator has given you access to it
you can use any of these services so
who's the service audience
who is using the active directory
service now there are three types of
audience when it comes to
your active directory the first one is
id administrator
the second one application developers
and online customers
so the idea administrators their main
emphasis is to ensure
that the sign-in takes place they take
care of all the sign-in procedures
they also solve issues when it comes to
authentication
for example to authenticate a particular
user the problem is solved by the idea
administrators
then you have application developers who
use these services
to develop applications and with this
they have an easier
time developing applications as all
these resources are easily available
you have online customers who make use
of services like office 365 and other
crm services
and have all their demands catered
immediately
so now let's have a look at how we can
use azure active directory to provide
access to a particular individual so if
you log into the azure account this is
what you see or you go into active
directory
a list of all the people who are using
or have been given permission to use
resources from azure
okay now we're going to create a profile
we need to set up his name which is
john and second name jacob
now for properties we need to determine
the source of authority which is already
active directory so that's fine we can
select a group
or add them to a particular group if we
feel like it
now if we add them to a particular group
it means that they have access to
all the resources that everyone in the
group has access to earlier
so we'll do that later we'll select
their directory role
or we can select it here if we need to
it could be user
administrator or a limited administrator
and now we'll set up a password
so we already got one and we'll create
and that's it we have created a user now
we'll go to their profile
so what we can see here is that you have
access to every bit of detail
related to this account so you have the
name your first name
the username the object id job info
everything you can even have other
details like how often they've signed in
when did they sign up you can check
their password you can reset the
password
delete their account and so much more
now we can even add a directory role
which we
saw earlier and now let's add this
person to the admin group
so you know he gets access to all the
services
those people have access to and select
that's it we've added them
now the other things that you can see
here there are applications licenses
devices
these are all restrictions you can add
or remove like
which device you can use the system
through or with and stuff like that
so that's it and with that we have
created a user and given him access to
certain services
we are going to talk about another
important as your service
as your data factory now why should you
be interested in data factory
now let's consider a scenario so here we
have two colleagues having a
conversation with each other
and they say that the data that they're
generating from their applications or
products
is increasing exponentially now
considering that this data is coming
from a number of different products
it'll be a bit of a task to analyze and
store all of this data
so he wonders how they're going to
manage that his friend suggests that
they use
azure's data factory now what does
azure's data factory actually do
first it stores data with the help of
the data link storage
now any kind of data can be stored in
the data lake storage
then you can analyze the data you can
transform the data with the help of
pipelines
and you can publish the organized data
you can visualize the data with
third-party applications like apache
spark or hadoop as well
now what exactly is data factory so now
let's have a look at what exactly
is data factory now data factory falls
under the identity domain of services in
the azure catalog
and is a cloud-based integration service
basically what it does is
it works on your data it stores your
data it orchestrates
and automates the movement or
transformation of data
it works heavily on the data that you
store now let's see how it actually
works or how
the flow of its processes are firstly we
have the input data set which is nothing
but the data that you have
within your data store the one that you
need processed then you pass this data
through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it which could be anything
from just data movement or some data
transformation
now data transformation is possible with
the help of usql
some stored procedures or hype now after
this is done
you get an output data set now this
output data set will contain data that
is in a structured form
because it's already been transformed
and made structured in the pipeline
stage
then it is given into linked services
like azure data lake block storage or
sql
now what it does is these store
information
that is very important when it comes to
connecting to an external source
now this is you know if you wanted an
example you know how in an sql server
you need to mention the source and
destination of your data
now for example consider an sql server
so you need a connection string so that
you can
connect to an external device you need
to mention the stores and the
destination of your data
this is how the link services work and
finally you need a gateway
now a gateway basically connects your
on-premises data
to the cloud so you do need a client
installed
on your on-premises system so that you
can connect to the azure cloud
and finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like apache spark r
hadoop and so on
so all this time i've been mentioning
that data lake is a very important part
when it comes to
azure data factories proper functioning
so now let's talk about
what exactly is data lake now data lake
is a data storage
or a file system which is highly
scalable and distributed
it is located in the cloud and works
with multiple analytics frameworks which
is
external frameworks like hadoop apache
and so on
so now let's have a look at it so first
you have your output data set which is
data from the mobile video
web social media so much more it is sent
into the azure data lake store
and then it is provided two external
frameworks like
r apache and spark so that they can be
worked on
now there are two main concepts when it
comes to data lake storage
so one of them is storage and the other
one is analytics
now storage is of unlimited size it can
be petabytes terabytes gigabytes and so
much more
it shows a wide variety of data it could
be unstructured or structured data
and it can store really large files and
another concept when it comes to
data lake is analytics now how it works
now
here are two examples of how analytics
works when it comes to data lake
now when it comes to analytics you can
monitor and diagnose real time data
for example data that you're getting
from vehicles or buildings these can be
used to optimize how they work
respond to certain events or generate
alerts in case something goes wrong
then you can also identify fraudulent
transactions
on your credit card or you can identify
the correct the geographical
position of your card perhaps monitor
how many transactions have been taking
place
on that card and so on so now we're
going to have a look at how we can use
the azure data factory
to move data from an sql database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do
so first off to make a database what
you're going to need a software known as
ssms so you can find it on google it's
called
you just need to google it ssms the
first link you can take here
and there you have it so you just need
to click here and download the file so
we i've already downloaded the file so
basically this is used to create a
database
which we'll be transferring to the blob
storage
so this will take about depending on
your computer speed pretty long or
little to no time i've already
downloaded it the process is very simple
just directly go on saying yes yes
and finally once installation is done
here's what we're going to do
we should go into the dashboard of
microsoft azure we need to create
a data warehouse so we'll go into all
resources
create a source go to database
and select sql data warehouse there we
have it
now it's very important that you
remember the names of the service
of everything that you're going to write
here because each of these become very
important later on
so i've already set up a possible set of
names
youtube it's free trial the source is
already created
a blank database the server we need to
create a new one
so that we'll name it as youtube server
youtube admin as the server admin login
the password as
all right the location does not matter
okay that's done now here the server is
done
and here we need to change how much you
want
the lowest i mean how much computation
you want how much did workload how
important your workload is so we'll put
it at the lowest since
we don't require much we'll apply the
rest is
normal and great so now we're creating
an sql data warehouse
so we'll wait so now the deployment is
done so we'll go
to the notification and go to the
resource here
now this is done so we'll go to the ssms
which i've already opened here
and then go here
and copy this paste it here sql
authentication login which details we
have already stored here
which is admin youtube admin and the
password which is also given there
right go to options we go to the
database
name which is youtube everything else is
there
you need to change it to tcp ip and
connect
we sign in
we'll add the password
and we're going to sign in now
right
so now that that's completed you can see
that this is what will pop
up so this is the name of the server
we've given as you saw
earlier we go to databases and here you
have the youtube database that we just
created
right click this and add a new query i
already have a code for this program
it's a very simple program so
copying and pasting this now if you need
the code for this program let us know in
the comments below it's very simple
what we're doing is creating a table
called demo tab with
first name clark kent and last name is
bruce wayne
and the table that's created will have
these two rows so now we're going to
execute this
there you have it two rows have been
affected so now let's have a look at our
table
execute this line and there you go the
table is here
so now that this is done we're going
back into azure
back and we need to create a storage
account so that's where the story where
the blob storage is going to happen so
we're going to storage accounts
and click on add so here it's a free
trial
resource group is youtube storage
account name
is
plea store that's
all okay u.s performance is standard
general purpose you can do locally since
we don't need to be very reliable at
least for this one
advance this fine view and create
that's done and we create now we'll wait
for the deployment to finish
and that's it the deployment is done so
we'll go to the resource
and go to blobs so this is where the
storage is happening we need to create a
blob
simply blob
which does not exist and okay
it has been created now for the next bit
we need to create the data factory now
so
we go to all services search for data
factory
we press add so here we
free trial use existing which we have
youtube
east us and create so now we've created
a new data factory
now we'll wait while it's being deployed
so now it's created so we'll go here and
here we click on copy data
and this opens up
we'll name it
our description run once
right so we press next so we need to
connect
to a data source so so what you need to
do
is select a secure as your sql data
warehouse
so once again you could previous here we
select
as your skill data warehouse go here
search for source
is your subscription free trial here
youtube server
and the databases youtube you also need
to provide your username and password
i've saved it here youtube admin
[Music]
right okay now we can select the table
which is
demo tab next
next and now for our destination so
where are we going to connect this to
we're going to azure blob storage next
destination job subscription free trial
and simply store now we need to name
our name our
storage path next all of this can be
passed on so here's what we're doing
it copying whatever is inside this to
the azure blob storage that's what's
happening right now
all of that is set and
next it's validating and we'll wait now
it's registering connections creating
database and
in the end it's creating a pipeline
so you can monitor the pipeline from
here if you feel like it
here's what we're going to find so
here's the here's a visual
representation of what's happening
it's being copied into the blob storage
now let's have a look if it's actually
worked out
go to our database we'll go into
storage accounts simply store
go to blobs
you created a new one
and there you have it so based on the
container that you've named there
it's created a new one here so actually
i earlier created the name called simply
blob
but as you can see here as long as you
name a container it'll create a folder
inside which you'll find your particular
thing that you copied
and that's it you've copied data
similarly you can do a number of
multiple
operations on this container on the on
the pipeline you just created with the
data factory
and that's that today we are going to
learn about the azure virtual machine
so without further ado let's get started
before getting in depth let me tell you
what's in store for today
first i'll be talking a little about
azure next
i'll start off by explaining the azure
virtual machine
then i'll be focusing on few benefits of
azure virtual machine
moving forward i'll be going in-depth
with the azure virtual machine
components
and finally we will be looking into a
demo on azure virtual machine
all of us may have heard of azure at one
point of time but what
is azir let me explain azir is a cloud
service created by microsoft for
building
testing and managing applications and
many services
through the microsoft data centers the
azir hosts web applications over the
internet with the help of these data
centers
azir is very flexible it gives an option
to have the functionality as required
you can pay as you consume switch to
azure and accommodate the business
fluctuations
there is no need to worry about the
infrastructure all the time azir is very
reliable and has 24 7 tech support
azure offers pay-as-you-go pricing and
hence it is very cost effective
staying online all the time ensures
customers or users trust
azure supports backup and disaster
recovery tools
now we know what azure is and its key
benefits let's now move on to azure
virtual machine before that let's
consider a scenario
ratio had to host 10 virtual machines at
once per project
there was an issue when her computer ram
was not compatible with the instances
the computer ram was only 8 gb and the
instances that required were 10 gb
then she says i wish there is a service
that's cost effective and also provides
extra ram memory
one of a colleague heard this and he
comes up with an idea
he says can we use azure virtual machine
it has a pay-as-you-go pricing
and has this for storage you can pay for
what you use
and create any number of instances with
high storage capacity
also if any technical difficulty arises
you can easily retrieve the files
through the backup
server so now she's happy and she wants
to know more about azure washing machine
azure virtual machine is one of the wide
range of services that azir offers to
create your instance
a virtual machine is a computer file
typically called an image which behaves
like an actual computer
it runs in a window giving the user the
same experience on a virtual machine
as they have on the host operating
system itself multiple virtual machines
can run simultaneously on the same
physical computer
each virtual machine provides its own
hardware like
cpus memories and other devices as your
virtual machine offers
a high range of flexibility and it
maintains the physical
hardware that runs on it let me explain
some of the benefits of azure virtual
machine
first we have easy development and test
azure virtual machine has a quick and
easy way to configure the computer that
is required to code and test an
application
next agility and scale azure virtual
machine
is agile and the ability to clone and
spin up multiple instances
of the same virtual machine allows us to
scale services
and applications rapidly efficiently and
very cost effectively
azure virtual machine provides enhanced
performance
demands for applications can fluctuate
so you pay for the virtual machines you
need and shut down the unnecessary ones
to save the cost
azure virtual machines provide extended
data center and can be easily
connected to an organization's network
it is easy to set up your redundant
infrastructure on azure and azure
provide the full
disaster recovery site at a fraction of
the cost furthermore
let me explain azure virtual machine
components in details
virtual machine comes under the compute
domain of azio
it also offers various services like
availability sets
snapshots disks images and many other
services like hosts
virtual machine can be clubbed with
other services like disk
images availability sets hosts and many
more
so the first component and the most
important component
is the operating system the operating
system creates connections to the remote
desktop session hosts there are many
operating systems available
like ubuntu red hat linux windows server
sent os you can also set the operating
disk size
so that the memory is not wasted the
next component
is disks azure virtual machines use
attached virtual hard disks for storage
there are two types of virtual hard
disks
first is an image there is a template
for creation of new azure virtual
machine
then we have disks it is a bootable
virtual hard disk
all durable disks are backed up by page
blobs in azure storage
therefore the discs inherit the benefits
of blob storage
high availability durability and many
more the discs are mounted as drives on
the vm
the next component is virtual network
many components operate the virtual
machines in a scalable and secure manner
virtual networks could include equipment
such as separate network spaces
for internet facing and backend servers
load balancers firewalls and more
many of these components are deployed
into an azure virtual network
azure virtual network provides many
features such as subnet ip address
load balancer and network security group
another important component of azure
virtual machine
is availability sets if in case there's
a slight chance there could be a failure
in physical servers
then these come into picture so in case
of such failure
the azure platform will migrate the
failed virtual machine to a healthy host
to reconstitute the vm it is highly
recommended to deploy at least two
instances of the virtual machine
and virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of functionalities
now that we know what azir virtual
machine is let's look into the demo
in this demo first we are going to
create a virtual machine
connect it and then create a web server
and modify the web server
and finally launch the web application
so let's go ahead into the demo now
so the first step is to log into
microsoft azure with your credentials
now let's click on virtual machines and
create a new one
so i can put add
and you can use the subscription you
want either pay as you go pricing or
free tire
resource group will create a new one
that is payroll
one okay virtual machine we can
create i'm gonna use vm web
zero zero one and then region
i'll be using east us
then image i'll be using windows server
r2 data center
size i'll be using b1 ms
select username
[Music]
and then password of your choice
and then i'm gonna allow selected ports
and choose rdp 3389
and next
so ost step i'll be using standard hdd
and then yeah next
so i can see a default virtual network
and a default submit in public ip as
well as default
then next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your choice
i'm going to select an extension to
install and i'm going to install
microsoft anti-malware
create okay
i'm going to create a few tags now let's
go ahead with it
so i've created five tags now review
plus create
okay so everything seems good let's
create now
so the deployment is going to take a few
minutes let's wait for it
okay so that's done now let's go to
virtual machine and see
our watching machine
okay so it's been deployed
now let's get into the virtual machine
and copy the ip address
then hit windows plus r
and open mstsc
and paste the ip address and connect
let's use a different account you have
to use the administrator account that
we've created before
with the same password
click ok
now the remote desktop session host
opens
the next step is to click on server
manager
and add rules and features
click on next select roll base of
feature based installation and click on
next
then select the watching machine you've
created and next
and then we are going to select
web server iis next
sorry
next okay so it's already installed my
computer but you have to install this
then let's close this and open internet
explorer
let's type in http
localhost
yeah so now we can see the default
browser opening
let's minimize this
and let's try it here
here we have just put the ip address
i think there's an issue
okay so let's add an inborn port
networking
select networking and add inbound port
let's move 480 and add
okay so it's added now let's go and
refresh it
now we can see the default web browser
opening so the next step is to modify
the web browser
let's go ahead with that go back to your
remote session host
let's go file explorer
so certain folders are created in the c
drive let's open that
it would be under eyelid pub
so this is where the default rose is
coming from now let's
make a new text document
open that and put
hello
welcome to this
demo by
simply learn
save it close it
let's rename this as
index dot ht
sorry
so this is a text document so we need to
change that
okay let's remove this
okay that's done
now let's go back to our internet
explorer and hit f5
let's refresh this
let's try one okay so let's
yeah so it's done now let's go back to
the previous browser
and try let's refresh yeah that's done
hi guys a very warm welcome so today's
topic is azure virtual network tutorial
let's look into what's in it for you so
we would be covering why is azure
virtual network important
what is azure virtual network is
benefits of using the azure virtual
network
components of azure virtual network that
includes the subnet
routing network security group why these
components are required to be created in
the virtual network
and how to launch an instance uh within
the
azure vnet or the virtual network and
then we will be seeing one demo in which
we will create azure virtual network
subnets and network security groups
so first of all let's look into why is
azure virtual network important
so why azure virtual network is required
so somewhere far away at an office a
company was struggling with few
challenges
the company got a bigger projects which
lead to the following challenges
that includes poor network connectivity
time consuming process and building
network topologies
could not divert network traffic to its
destination on time
so these were a couple of challenges the
company was facing so
the employees thought that what could be
the possible solution to these
challenges
and then we require the azure virtual
network in that case
so first of all let's understand what is
azure virtual network is
an azure vnet or a virtual network
represents your network or environment
to run vms and applications in the
cloud when it is created
the services and virtual machines within
the network interact securely
with each over the internet so virtual
network you can consider it as a virtual
cloud
which is basically kind of a cloud
space virtually assigned to the users or
or to the organization which they can
dedicatedly use
for their purpose so for example if you
have to create some
uh instances or virtual machines on to
the azure cloud
and you want to connect it with the
on-prem
servers for example then you might
require the virtual network in that case
let's assume that those instances that
are created in the virtual network
require the range of ip addresses that
you want to allocate to them
and that is something you can customize
using the azure virtual network
how do you want that the traffic should
be routed
to your instances in the virtual network
how the firewall securities should be
applied
everything the end user can control
in the virtual network so it seems like
that you are working in your own data
center
ideally you would be working on to the
azure cloud
using the virtual network now what are
the advantages of using the azure
virtual network
so couple of them are it provides an
isolated environment for your
application so as i said that it feels
like it seems like
that you are working in your on-prem
environment that means within your data
center
but ideally it is a virtual space that
is allocated to you
which is a kind of an isolated
environment and that is specifically
designed
for your tasks and the activities a
generally a subnet in a
v-net can access the public internet by
default so we create a subnet inside
the virtual network which can access the
public
internet so there is a public network
connectivity that is
enabled in the virtual net so that a
subnet which will be created in the
v-net can be
accessed traffic can be easily filtered
from different resources so you can have
some
control list defined you can have some
security groups created
and how do you want to allow the traffic
onto the servers or the application that
is something which you can control
it is a highly secure network and the
security groups and the policies are
basically implemented by the end user so
you can design
how the security should be implemented
high
network connectivity so you have a
higher bandwidth as compared to the
normal internet connection you might be
having in the data center
compared to that you use the azure
network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity
it builds sophisticated network
topologies in a simple
manner and which is easily manageable
as well as there are less
troubleshooting issues
that we would encounter
now what are the components of azure
virtual network
one of them is the subnets
then you have routing then you have
network security groups now what do we
mean by
subnets the subnet is one of the
major or a prime important component in
the virtual network so what you have to
do is first
obviously you would be creating a
virtual network inside that you can
create the subnets
subnets you can consider it a logical
partitioning
virtual partitioning inside the virtual
network
subnet lets user segment the virtual
network
into one or more sub networks for
example let's assume
that you're working in an organization
and in the organization there are
different departments
for every department there should be
some set of ip addresses that you want
to allocate to
the machines that the employees are
using or
all the department should be isolated
that means they should have their own
network ids and the network addresses
allocated to their machines and in that
case
what you would do is you would create
the subnets and the subnet ids
that would be allocated to those
departments these sub networks can be
separated logically
and each subnet consists of a server so
what you do is when you create a subnet
you can you can create a server or an
instance inside that subnet
and how do you want to give an access to
that instance depends on
criteria or the requirement hence a
subnet can further be divided into two
parts
one as the public subnet and the other
one as the private subnet
these are the naming conventions of the
subnet then how do you want to give the
internet connectivity depends on
how the public subnet should be
interacting with the internet
and for the private subnet as the name
suggests that the
internet is blocked so that means it is
completely isolated in the
virtual network the private instances
though if you want
that any instance created in the private
subnet should have the internet
connectivity or an access
you can primarily go with the nat
gateways in that case which is a network
address translation or
kind of a translator which converts the
private to public and vice versa
and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your
subnets then in the public instances
they can directly access the instance as
the name suggests public instances that
public subnets that means they have the
direct
internet connectivity next component is
routing and the routing is primarily
a routing rules you can say that are
applied
and those are actually applied to
the routers only so since on the cloud
we cannot have a direct router access
and hence using the routing as a
component we can define some routing
rules which are
directly applied to the router and the
infrastructure
it delivers the data by choosing a
suitable path from source to
destination for each subnet azure
virtual network automatically routes
traffic and creates a
route table when you create a virtual
network automatically a route table is
created and that basically is required
to
route the traffic and that can be used
by every subnet that doesn't mean that
you only have to create
a single route table in the virtual
network you can have multiple route
tables also created
which can be associated with different
subnets as well
then you have the network security
groups it is kind of a firewall that
protects the virtual machine by limiting
the
network traffic it restricts inbound and
outbound
network traffic depending upon the
destination ip address transport
and the protocol so it is basically
the network security group sits on the
instances
and or virtual machines and
they basically define that how
the traffic should be reaching to the
ports onto the virtual machine so how do
you want to open up the ports
and for which ip addresses you want to
open up the ports
that is something the end user or the
administrator has to
specify our design so they act as a
kind of a firewall rules only that
protects the virtual machines
so how to launch an instance using azure
vnet
so first of all you have to create a
virtual network so virtual network act
as a container for subnets so first
thing is that you would be creating a
virtual network
then you would be creating subnets which
are
considered as a subset within the
virtual network so cloud instance is
included in the subnet
so first vnets are created then the
subnets are created
and then you configure the properties in
the security group
have a look at this in detail now with
respect to the virtual network what you
need to do is you have to create a
virtual network in the azure cloud
then you have to create subnets into
each virtual network which is kind of a
subset of a virtual network
so you can create one as a public subnet
the other one as a private subnet for
example now you have to assign
instances so when you create an instance
you have to specify that what is the
virtual network
for which virtual network you are
creating an instance within that virtual
network
you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created and then connect instance to a
relevant
network security group so attach your
network security group to the instances
and based on the properties or the rules
that are defined in the network security
group that will be applied to the
instances within the subnets
finally configure the properties in the
network security
and set the policies as a result you
will be able to launch your instance
on azure within the virtual network
now we will be seeing one demo that how
we can create azure virtual network
subnets and the network security group
so
just be there uh to watch our demo
on the azure virtual network in today's
session i would be showing how you can
create the virtual networks
onto the azure and for that you require
the credentials on microsoft azure and
here you can see on my screen
that i have already logged in into the
azure console now what you need to do is
in order to search virtual network you
can type
and search in the dashboard in the
search bar
with respect to the virtual networks and
here you can find
uh the virtual network and the gateways
so what you need to do is you just have
to click on the virtual networks
and then it will give you the options to
add
the components inside the virtual
networks
so let me first open up the virtual
network
right now in theory we discussed that
the virtual network comprises of
multiple components and sub components
so primarily is that first you have to
create a virtual network
then you have to assign the ipv4 cidr
block to the virtual network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset
of the virtual network along with that
you define the routing rules
and likewise you create the
instances inside the subnets that will
be part of the virtual networks
so that's what we are going to do uh in
this demo so i would be adding up
a new virtual network so you can see
here there are already two virtual
networks that have been added
one is the demo v-net which is by
default so when you created the azure
credentials
the demo virtual network was already
created by the azure so that it can
provide you the
default settings and then the test one
has been created by me and that's the
customized one or you can say a
non-default
virtual network so i'll i'm going to add
another
v-net and would define
the name to it so let's wait for
the details to appear so here you have
to define the virtual network to create
obviously we will be going with the free
trial only
and then you have to create a resource
group so what is a resource group it is
primarily a collection of resources that
share the same life cycle permissions
and the policies
so if you have a resource group created
you can use it
otherwise you can create a new resource
group so i already have one
that is the demo one i would be using
that
in the instance details you have to
specify the name of the virtual network
so
these are certain parameters that you
have to go with
while defining the name so let's say i
put something like
test v-net as
the virtual network that i want to
create and that is you have to select
a region where you want to get that
created
so these are the available regions that
you can select i would go
with us east east us only
and then we have to define the ip
addresses also see
so in the ip addresses uh the cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks
and that becomes a fixed ip address for
that we net
so what you can do is you can specify a
range of ip addresses now whenever we
talk about a virtual network and the ip
addresses
we primarily focus on the private ips
only
so this is the private ip that we are
actually
talking about so i can reserve some ip
address
cidr for our v-net and that is
the range of 40.0.0.0 16.
i'm going to reserve so now we'll create
one subnet and
we'll name that subnet so as we
discussed that subnets are the sub
components of
the vnet so here you can see we have
already created one
subnet with the name public subnet so
likewise we can add another subnet also
and let's name it to something like
demo subnet right and the subnet should
have the ip address range and that
ip address range should be part of the
vnet only did inviting
so same subnet address range you would
be defining in the
subnet as well so that will be forty dot
zero dot one dot
or we can select two dot zero slash
twenty four
the rest of the things uh would be
default uh we are not attaching any
route table as of now so just click on
ok and here you can see that
the subnet is created now once
the subnet is created now we are going
to create a virtual machine
inside that subnet and for that we will
go to the search bar
and here we'll type virtual machines
now we'll create a virtual machine in
the same v-net
that is the test v-net and inside the
demo
subnet so that our virtual machine gets
the private ip address from the subnet
that has been created in the
v-net itself so what you need to do is
you have to open up the virtual machines
click on add
and here you should add a new virtual
machine
so you should select the name of the
virtual machine and
the network details where we would be
defining
the v-net as well as the subnet where
the virtual machine should be created
so in the subscription we'll go with the
free tail and in the resource group
we'll go with the demo that has already
been created we'll
put a virtual machine name something
like
test vm and the rest of the things will
be default
so we'll quickly skip the disk check
also
now in the networking we would be
selecting
the test v-net as our virtual network
and in the subnet we would be selecting
the demo subnet
so that is the recently one added in the
test v-net and we want
that our virtual machine should be part
of that subnet only
now obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public ip also
assigned since from the public network
we need to access
those virtual machines so we'll keep it
enabled right and the next
would be the default settings that we
are going to proceed with
so let's review all the configurations
and then create your virtual machine
so here you can see that our virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that
updated so let's wait for a few more
minutes so that our virtual machine is
ready
and primarily what we want to look into
is that our virtual machine is created
in a correct we net
and it gets the private ip address from
the subnet that has been part of the
vnet which has been defined in the
creation of a virtual machine
so let's wait for a couple of more
minutes and we'll look into
the status of the now you can see here
our test virtual machine has been
created now what we wanted to look into
is that
our virtual machine is created in a
correct subnet or not
and that is something which we can
validate by
checking the private ip address so it
got the private ip from the range of
the ip address that we have specified in
the subnet
now in order to access this particular
virtual machine you have to
use the public ip since uh
since we have to access it from the
internet so
from the private ip this virtual machine
will not be accessible
so that's the reason that when we
created a virtual machine we allocated
the public ip address also for this
instance
so that is with respect to uh the
virtual network
and the demonstration on it and how we
can
create a v-net and the sub-components of
the v-net how they are
associated or interlinked with each
other and
that actually creates a kind of an
isolated environment on the
public cloud which gives you the
understanding that
you can work into just like an
on-prem environment today we will
discuss what should an individual learn
in the year 2021
let's wait for an ample amount of time
so that few more people can tune in
by the time please allow me to tell you
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies
so if you are the tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon so
that you can never miss an update from
our end
so we have a few more people now hi
everyone
welcome to simply learn so without
further ado
let's get started back in the 2000s
organizations were utterly dependent on
purchase servers
for their it infrastructure these
servers
not only came with limited functionality
but were also
very expensive the traditional way of
storing and managing data
was costly and complicated it required a
massive amount of hardware
and complex software to run all these
issues were resolved using cloud
computing
rather than owning their computing
infrastructures organizations were able
to scale up or scale down resources
based on the requirement companies
providing these computing services
are called as cloud providers according
to c sharp corner
the two popular cloud providers in the
cloud market are
amazon aws and microsoft azure
now let's take a step back and talk
about a question
what should an individual learn in the
year 2021
amazon web services or microsoft azure
though this question is tricky we need
to understand which cloud provider is
the best option to choose
now let's take a brief look at both of
these cloud providers
amazon web services is an evolving cloud
computing platform
that offers various services such as
compute power
storage database content delivery and
other resources to help business
scale and grow aws services are provided
based on a subscription basis
similarly microsoft azure provides a set
of cloud services
to design create and monitor
applications on a network
talking about the general features
amazon web services
was established in the year 2006. today
it holds a market share of 31.7 percent
whereas microsoft azure was started in
the year
2010 and now has a market share up to
16.8 percent amazon aws is the world's
most broadly adopted cloud platform
it offers up to 165 services
globally these services are used by
millions of companies like spotify
netflix facebook bbc etc
talking about netflix the company moved
its id operations to aws in the year
2009.
aws was able to solve the company's
scalability
and data management issues azure offers
several services in various categories
including artificial intelligence
analytics containers iot and many more
these services are used by many famous
companies like accenture
linkedin stack ebay and samsung
accenture chose microsoft azure to boost
productivity
and provide better security to its
employees
the aws pricing model is based on an
hourly basis with aws
every individual pays only for the
services that are required
for his work every person only pays for
the services he consumes
azure pricing is charged on a per minute
basis
the payment system is very simple and
doesn't involve
any long-term contracts microsoft azure
is free of upfront cost and cancellation
fees
and only users pay for the resources
they consume
with azure and amazon aws there are no
additional costs
or termination fees moving on to the
next
factor let's talk about availability
zones
availability zones are isolated data
centers with
independent power and networking these
zones protect
applications and files from data center
failures
in total aws has nearly
77 availability zones within 24
geographic regions
around the world the company plans to
establish
nine more aws availability zones and
three more aws regions in indonesia
japan and spain on the other hand
microsoft azure has many isolated
availability zones
these zones are located within an azure
region and they provide fast network
connectivity
azure has 44 availability zones around
the world
the company is planning to launch 12
more zones
now after discussing the availability
zones let's talk about the services
the services that i am going to compare
here come under the following domains
compute storage database
security and finally networking
aws and azure provide a wide variety of
services
with low migration costs so that every
individual can shift
his or her current traditional
infrastructure to cloud platform
very easily aws ec2
is a suitable example of compute
services
ec2 is a web service that aims to make
life easier for developers by providing
secure and resizable compute capacity in
the cloud
it can be integrated to several other
services like s3
iam cloudformation etc
azure has a small service called as your
virtual machine image
it helps the developers to develop and
design
identical virtual machines in the matter
of minutes
azure virtual machines are becoming more
popular among
id infrastructures these machines let
an individual create and use virtual
machines
in the cloud as ias
or infrastructure as a service virtual
machines can be created using azure
portal
as your powershell and arm templates
as your cli or client software
development kits
next comes amazon s3 it is the best
example for storage service
simple storage service is an object
storage service designed to store and
recover
any information from anywhere via the
internet
amazon s3 facilitates storage through a
web service interface
the service provides 99.9 durability and
99.9 percent availability of objects
it has the capacity of storing computer
files up to
5 terabytes in size on the other hand
azure provides a similar service called
blob storage
service this service provides a large
amount of storage
and is highly scalable it stores an
object in the tires depending
on how often the data is being accessed
blob storage supports widely used
frameworks like java
dot net bison and node.js
it is the only cloud storage service in
microsoft azure that offers a premium
ssd based object storage tire for low
latency networks
aws provides a secure cloud platform
where every individual can manage
and deploy their applications compared
to the on-premises environment
aws security offers a high level of data
protection
at a lower cost for security purposes
iam is a suitable service aws identity
and access management is a cloud service
that controls and manages aws resources
securely
it has no upfront cost also gives a
facility to create and maintain services
within a specific set of users on your
aws
resources in microsoft azure azure
active directory or in short also called
as azure ad
is a web service which provides mfa
multi-factor authentication features
to users in order to protect their data
from cyber attacks
next is amazon rds it is a web service
designed to simplify the setup operation
and scaling of
a relational database it is simple to
set up
use and scale when required by users
it provides inexpensive and resizable
capacity and
automates several tasks such as hardware
provisioning
database setup patching and backups on
the other side the
azure sql database automatically updates
and backups data
in order to focus on the development of
applications
not just that it also manages database
services and response to client
requirements
client requirements such as scalability
of a service
data backup and high availability of
database
similarly these cloud providers have
plenty of services
that help users build and deploy their
applications effectively
moving on to the next topic let us focus
on integrating aws
and azure with open source tools now
we will explain how to build a pipeline
using jenkins along with one of the
services of amazon web services
that is the ec2 in this integration
process
we have a sample python application
called as a docker file
this dockerfile will consist of a python
base image
the docker file builds a pipeline in
order to create a docker image upon
pushing the code to the repository later
the new image is used to start a new aws
service on
an ecs cluster now let's have a look at
how the integration of open source tools
happen in azure in your azure cloud
application
devops tools like docker maven and
jenkins can be integrated
in case you want to integrate the
jenkins pipeline go to project
and create a subscription followed by
jenkins
you can specify the required filters
based on your requirement
then choose your endpoint for azure
devops to communicate with
jenkins so that was all about amazon aws
and microsoft azure
both aws and azure are honored to be on
top of
all other cloud providers both provide
all necessary features like scalability
high availability and security but the
moment i hear about choosing the best
one
i have to say that all that depends upon
the individual business needs
both cloud providers are the certified
ones that hold immense value in the
current cloud service market
hey guys i'm rahul and i'll be
representing amazon web services
i'm chinmayi and i'll be representing
microsoft azure
and i'm shruti and i'll be representing
google cloud platform
so welcome to this video on aws versus
azure vs gcp
talking about market share amazon web
services leads with around 32 percent
of the worldwide public cloud share
azure owns up to 16
of the worldwide market share and gcp
owns around 9
of the world's market share let's talk
about each of these service providers in
detail
aws provides services that enable users
to create and deploy
applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the internet
aws being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006.
azure launched in 2010 is a computing
platform that offers a wide range of
services
to build manage and deploy applications
on the network
using tools and frameworks launched in
the year 2008
gcp offers application development and
integration services for its end users
in addition to cloud management it also
offers services for big
data machine learning and iot now let's
talk about availability zones
these are isolated locations within data
center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about aws
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions
this includes regions in the united
states south america europe and asia
pacific they are also predicted to have
12 more editions in the future
azure available in 140 countries has
over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers
gcp is available in 200 plus countries
across the world
as of today gcp is present in 61 zones
and 20 regions with osaka and zurich
being the newly added regions
now let's talk about pricing these
services follow the pay-as-you-go
approach
you pay only for the individual services
you need for as long as you use them
without requiring long-term contracts or
complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers
with respect to various instances like
general purpose
compute optimized memory optimized and
gpu now let's talk about the compute
services offered
first off we have virtual servers for
aws
we have ec2 it is a web service which
eliminates the need to invest in
hardware
so that you can develop and deploy
applications in a faster manner
it provides virtual machines in which
you can run your applications
azure's virtual machines is one of the
several types of computing resources
that azure offers
azure gives the user the flexibility to
deploy and manage a virtual environment
inside a virtual network gcp's vm
service enables users to build
deploy and manage virtual machines to
run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aw cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws free tier
that lasts for 12 months and provides
750 hours per month of both linux and
windows virtual machines
azure virtual machine service is a part
of the free tier that offers this
service for about 750 hours per month
for a year the user gets access to
windows and linux virtual machines
gcp's vm service is a part of a free
tier that includes micro instance
per month for up to 12 months now let's
talk about platform as a service or pass
services
for aws elastic bean stock is an easy to
use service for deploying and scaling
web applications and services
developed with java.net node.js python
and much more
it is used for maintaining capacity
provisioning load balancing
auto scaling and application health
monitoring the pass backbone utilizes
virtualization techniques where the
virtual machine
is independent of the actual hardware
that hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying hardware
google app engine is a cloud computing
platform as a service which is used by
developers for hosting and building apps
in google data centers
the app engine requires the apps to be
written in java or python
and store data in google bigtable and
use the google query language for this
next let's talk about virtual private
server services aws provides light sale
it provides everything you need to build
an application or website along with the
cost effective monthly plan
and minimum number of configurations in
simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service
next up we have serverless computing
services aws has lambda
it is a serverless compute service that
lets you run your code without
facilitating and managing servers
you only pay for the compute time you
use it is used to execute backend code
and scales automatically when required
azure functions is a serverless compute
service that lets you run even triggered
code without having to explicitly
provision
or manage infrastructure this allows the
users to build applications using
serverless simple functions with the
programming language of their choice
gcp cloud functions make it easy for
developers to run and scale code in the
cloud and build image driven serverless
applications
it is highly available and fault
tolerant now let's talk about storage
services
offered by each of these service
providers first off we have object
storage
aws provides s3 it is an object storage
that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information
or data from anywhere over the internet
blob storage is an azure feature that
lets
developers store unstructured data in
microsoft's cloud platform
along with storage it also offers
scalability it stores the data in the
form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed
google cloud storage is an online
storage web service for storing and
accessing data on google cloud platform
infrastructure
unlike the google drive google cloud
storage is more suitable for enterprises
it also stores objects that are
organized into buckets
amazon provides ebs or elastic block
store it provides high performance block
storage
and is used along with ec2 instances for
workloads that are transaction
or throughput intensive azure managed
disk is a virtual hard disk
you can think of it like a physical disk
in an on-premises server but virtualized
these managed disks allow the users to
create up to 10 000 vm disks in a single
subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data
after power to the device is shut off
google persistent disk is durable
and high performance block storage for
gcp persistent
disk provides storage which can be
attached to instances running in either
google compute engine or
kubernetes engine next up we have
disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure
and data are recovered while minimizing
the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages
it allows recovery by orchestrating and
automating the replication process of
azure virtual machines between regions
unfortunately gcp has
no disaster recovery service next let's
talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service
it is a web service that's cost
effective and automates administration
tasks
basically it simplifies the setup
operation and scaling of a relational
database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform
that includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance
reliability and data protection it also
eases the migration of sql server
databases without changing the user's
applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up
maintain and administer relational
postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud
hosted on gcp cloud sql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere
next we have nosql database services aws
provides dynamodb which is a managed
durable database that provides security
backup and restore and in-memory caching
for applications
it is well known for its low latency and
scalable performance
azure cosmos db is microsoft's globally
distributed multi-model database service
it natively supports nosql it natively
supports nosql
created for low latency and scalable
applications gcp cloud data store is a
nosql database service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication
and scales automatically to your
application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target
now let's talk about the key cloud tools
for each of these service providers
for aws in networking and content
delivery we have aws route 53 and aws
cloudfront for management we have aws
cloudwatch in aws cloud formation
for development we have aws code start
and aws code build for security we have
iam
and key management service for microsoft
azure networking and content delivery we
have content delivery network and
express route for management tools we
have azure advisor
and network watcher for development
tools for management we have azure
advisor
and network watcher for development we
have visual studio ide
and azure blob studio for security we
have azure security center and azure
active directory
for gcp we have the following tools for
networking and content delivery we have
cloud cdn and cloud dns
for management we have stack driver and
gcp monitoring for development we have
cloud
build and cloud sdk and finally for
security we have google cloud im
and google and cloud security scanner
now let's talk about the companies using
these cloud providers for aws we have
netflix unilever
kellogg's nasa nokia and adobe pixar
samsung
ebay fujitsu emc and bmw among others
use microsoft azure
so as seen on your screens the companies
that use gcp are spotify hsbc
snapchat twitter paypal and 20th century
fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone
and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources aws is designed to allow
application providers
isvs and vendors to quickly and securely
host your applications whether an
existing application or a new sas based
application
speed and agility aws provides you
access to its services within minutes
all you need to select is what you
require and you can proceed you can
access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment
it secures and hardens your
infrastructure more importantly it
provides security at a cheaper cost than
on-premise environments
now talking about some of the advantages
of azure microsoft azure offers better
development operations
it also provides strong security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess
diagnose stabilize and close azure also
provides a cost-effective solution the
cloud environment allows businesses to
launch both customer applications
and internal apps in the cloud which
saves an id infrastructure costs
hence it's opex friendly let's now look
at the advantages of gcp
google builds in minute level increments
so you only pay for the compute time you
use
they also provide discounted prices for
long running workloads for example you
use the vm for a month
and get a discount gcp also provides
live migration of virtual machines
live migration is the process of moving
a running vm from one physical server to
another
without disrupting its availability to
the users this is a very important
differentiator for google cloud compared
to other cloud providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a site's container scale to as
many cpus as needed
google cloud storage is designed for
99.9
durability it creates server backup and
stores them in an user configure
location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for aws there's a limitation of the ec2
service aws provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region
there may be a limit to the number of
instances that can be created however
you can request for these limits to be
increased secondly they have a technical
support fee aws charges you for
immediate support and you can opt for
any of these packages
developer which costs 29 dollars per
month business which costs more than
hundred dollars
an enterprise that costs more than
fifteen thousand dollars it has certain
network
connectivity issues it also has general
issues when you move to the cloud
like downtime limited control backup
protection and so on
however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of microsoft azure code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud
pass echo system is not as efficient as
iaas
azure management console is frustrating
to work with it is slow to respond and
update and requires far too many clicks
to achieve simple tasks
azure backup is intended for backing up
and restoring data located on your
on-premises servers to the cloud
that's a great feature but it's not
really useful for doing bare metal
restores of servers in a remote data
center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp
so when it comes to cloud providers the
support fee is very minimal but in the
case of gcp it is quite costly
it is around 150 dollars per month for
the most basic service
similar to aws s3 gcp has a complex
pricing
schema also it is not very budget
friendly when it comes to downloading
data from
google cloud storage i would like to
welcome you to this azure interview
preparation
session knowing azure is one thing
having worked on azure is another thing
and being able to answer interview
questions in
azure is a totally different thing
although one helps the other
it's still different skills and our aim
through this video is to prepare you
with common
product and scenario based interview
questions
so why wait let's get started a common
cloud interview question is what's the
difference between sas
pass and is we all know that uh
software as a service is thin client
model
of software provisioning where client
in this case usually is simply a web
browser
providing the point of access to
software's running
on the servers now sas is the most
familiar form of cloud service for
customers sas moves the task of managing
software
and its deployment to third-party
services meaning
the vendor actually gets to manage all
that so
sas is software as a service involving
applications being consumed and used by
organization so it's generally using an
application
and usually organizations pay for their
use
of this particular application now some
examples of
sas would include office 365 salesforce
is another
very good example of sas and a lot of
google apps and storage solutions like
box and dropbox are a very good example
of
software as a service talking about
platform as a service
or pass it actually functions at the
lower level than
sas now typically it provides a platform
on which
software can be developed and deployed
now
here we develop the software we deploy
the software
now pass actually provides an abstract
of
much of the work dealing with servers
and
giving client an environment in which
the operating system and the
server software and the hardwares and
the network
are managed and taken care in other
words
with a platform as a service all the
things that i've mentioned
like the servers the server software the
hardware
everything is managed by the provider
and we can
focus on business side of the
scalability
and we can focus on application
development of
our product or the service so in short
platform as a service
is a service that enables developers to
build and work with applications
without even having to worry about the
infrastructure or management of the
underlying hosting
environments and some examples of pass
in azure is sql and azure
storage talking about infrastructure as
a service i
as now this is moving down the stack
even further now we get to the
fundamental building block of the cloud
service which is
infrastructure as a service is now is
is fully of highly automated scalable
computer resources
is full of storage is full of
the network capability that's what i as
is
now is clients have direct access to the
servers
and storage just as they would to do
traditional servers
but in this case it's going to be in the
cloud in this case it's going to be more
scalable so
is very similar to what you would do in
your
on-premises physical data center but
when we talk about is we get to do
everything but it's stored in the cloud
so if we need to build a definition
around is is or infrastructure as a
service
provides users with components it
provides components it does not give us
a
built environment it simply provides a
component such as
operating system networking capabilities
and
a lot more now this is a paid for
based on the usage and can be used to
host applications in other words this is
pay as you go type the more you use the
more you pay the less you use
the less you pay and some of the
examples of is in azure is a
virtual machine that's a great example
for is
and v-nets for networking that's another
good example for is
in azure another common question in
azure interview is what are the instant
types offered by azure
the main intention of this question is
how well have you understood the
different offerings in azure and how
well
are you trained to pick the right
offering for
the right service now one size does not
fit all and there are
there are a lot of services in azure
that under the carpet it does the same
thing
but depending on how different your
requirement is
we'll have to pick the appropriate
server so this actually this question
what are the different instant types
offered by azure it's to test
how well have you used the product and
services available in azure
and how well have you applied them for
the given requirement
you should be provisioning more you
should be provisioning less at the same
time so it's kind of matching the right
service
to the right requirement so what are the
instant types offered by azure
as you see in the list we have general
purpose compute optimized
memory optimized storage optimized gpu
virtual machines and high performance
compute virtual machines now
answering just the names won't be enough
in an interview you'll have to go
further and explain
why and in what scenario you would use
general purpose
and what are the use cases what type of
servers
is a good fit for a general purpose and
what type is a good fit for compute
optimized
so on and so forth and that's exactly
what we're going to do now so the
general purpose vms
you know they provide a balanced cpu to
memory ratio and it's very good for
testing very good for a development
environment
very good for small and medium databases
and also for low to medium traffic web
servers
and some of the use cases are like we
said test servers
low traffic web servers small to medium
databases
some enterprise great applications it's
also good for relational database it's
also good for
servers used for in-memory caching it's
also good for
some small analytic database very good
for
microservices and if you're trying to
build a proof of concept
for an idea that you just have or just
parked
this is another good server for doing
proof of
concepts because you're not going to
send actual traffic to it
i just want to show that you know your
idea works so
general purpose server is a very good
use case for those scenarios
and the largest instance size we can get
in general purpose is
standard d64 v3 which comes with 256
gigabit of memory and
1600 gigabit of ssd temporary storage
on the other hand compute optimized vms
have an
a high cpu to memory ratio and are very
good for
medium traffic web servers very good for
batch processing servers
very good for application servers now
because it's computer optimized and
compute means a cpu
it's an excellent choice for workloads
that demand
faster cpu but does not need as much
memory or temporary storage virtual cpu
some of the workloads that run very well
on computer optimized are analytic
workloads
gaming servers require more cpu they run
really well
batch processing are some of the
applications that can be
placed in compute optimized and by doing
that we get the actual benefit of the
compute optimized
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instance size
type is standard f72s v2
and here we get 144 gigabit of memory
and 576 gigabit of ssd temporary storage
in compute optimized vms in the same
lines
memory optimized to vm they offer high
memory to cpu ratio and that are great
for
databases databases require more memory
so it's a great fit
for database and it's a great fit for
medium to
large scale caches applications that
require
in-memory analytics so this memory
optimized
memory is more so it's very good for
in-memory analytics applications
and the largest instant size we get here
is standard
m 128 m and look at the
gigabit of memory it's 3892
gigabit of memory and look at the
temporary storage it's uh 1400
336 a gigabit of temporary storage
on the same lines storage optimized now
i guess i don't have to explain to you
what storage optimized is used for you
might have
easily guessed looking at the flow yes
storage
optimized vm offer high
disk throughput and ion are very ideal
for
big data sql nosql databases
data warehousing servers large
transactional databases
and lot more and some of the examples of
the applications that can be
launched on storage optimized are
cassandra
mongodb cloudera redis these are some
familiar
applications that can get benefited when
we run them on storage optimized
and one difference between storage
optimized and the other servers are
they are generally optimized to use the
local disk on the node attached
directly to the vm rather than using an
durable
disk which is actually in a remote
disk space now what does this allow this
allows for
greater input outputs per second or
throughput for the workload so that's
what we get
a greater throughput a greater input
outputs per second is what we get
when we use storage optimized and the
largest instance size available in
storage optimized
is a standard l32s and
the memory is 256 gigabit and look at
the
temporary storage it's a 5630 gigabit
of temporary storage gpu type vms
easy to guess gpu optimized vms are
specialized virtual machines available
with multiple gpus attached to them
now these sizes are designed for or
these vms are designed for
compute intensive graphic intensive
visualization
workloads that require a lot of
graphical processing unit attached to it
so in short these are virtual machines
that specialize
in heavy graphic rendering and video
editing
it also helps with model training and
interferencing with the
standard nd 24 rs which has uh
448 gigabit of memory and 2948
gigabit of temporary storage and the
last but not the least
but the best last but the best is
high performance compute or azure h
series virtual machines
now they are the latest in high
performance computing
vms and are aimed to handle workloads
like
batch processing analytic molecular
modeling and fluid dynamics a lot of
complicated applications
in this vm and this is the fastest and
powerful
cpu virtual machine with optional
high throughput interfaces and the
largest instance size
that's available is a standard l32s
which comes with 224 gigabit of memory
and 200 gigabit of
ssd temporary storage and a third common
question is
what are the deployment environments
offered by
azure there are two main deployment
environments
one is the staging environment and the
other one is the production
environment now in staging environment
let's talk about staging first
so when you are deploying your web app
or web app on linux
you can deploy them to a separate slot
instead of the default production slot
when running them
in standard premium or isolated app
service plan tiers
now the deployments slots are actually
live app
with their own host name and at a later
point that the staging environment can
be swapped with the
production environment so why do we need
and staging environment what are the
benefit
of it so the benefit of deploying our
application to a non-production
or staging environment it provides a
platform
to validate changes to our application
before it can be made live
in the production environment and in the
staging environment the app can be
identified
using the azure's global unique
identifier also called as
the guid url and it's very very similar
to the production url except that it has
a custom name
in front of it that identifies it as the
staging
environment and for production
environment this is
the live production environment that's
serving
customers request that serving the
customer content
now it can be slightly different from
the staging environment in a way that
the url that's used to identify the
production environment
that's more often dns friendly name
like the name of the actual service dot
cloud app.net that way it differs in
case of staging environment you have an
custom name right before it so the
custom name and then
the cloudapp.net but in this case you
get
the direct service name as the name of
the url
so this is live production environment
which
receives and handles and serves customer
traffic another commonly asked question
in azure is what are the advantages of
scaling in
azure the actual thought behind the
question is to see
how much have you understood scaling how
much have you
seen and how much have you applied the
scaling effect in the production
environment and
have received benefits in return so
let's talk about it advantages of
scaling in azure
some of the advantages are we get the
maximum
application performance now auto scaling
is a built-in feature
for the cloud services be it aws azure
google and couple of other cloud service
providers it's a built-in feature
for a cloud service a cloud service
should be auto scalable
and that includes mobile services
virtual machines
and when we run our applications on
mobile services or virtual machines
the website actually gets the best
performance
during the change in the demand again
different applications might require
different
performance needs for examples for some
apps the performance
measured based on memory and another a
good example
is the fluctuating demand for example
you could have a web app that handles
millions of requests during the day and
literally nothing at the night and auto
scaling this environment auto scaling
uh any of these environment will
automatically scale
or fatten your environment so to receive
the all the incoming traffic and
during lean period it actually gets
slimmer and slimmer
so to help you with the cost so it
actually maximizes
the performance that's what auto scaling
does and
like we said auto scaling scales up and
scales down
based on demand it not only scales up
but also scales down
so to help you with the cost and if you
know the particular pattern
in which the application is going to
receive traffic
then we can very well go ahead and
schedule scaling
to our application or schedule scaling
that infrastructure
based on time if we already know that
monday to friday that's the traffic
uh that i would get and it's a constant
one it's not a public facing but you
know it's an internal application so i
know
all the 500 users or the thousand or the
5000 users who'll be using it so
at any given point it's just 5 000 users
it's not going to go
beyond that and during saturday and
sunday literally nobody's going to be in
office
so no load at all so in that case i
pretty much
know how the pattern is going to be i
can go for scheduled scaling
if i know at the pattern and auto
scaling like i said
not only helps with keeping the
application highly available
it also helps with the cost
effectiveness
of our infrastructure so anytime there's
a vm
or a group of vms running on less cpu
auto scaling is going to actually
get the environment slimmer and slimmer
so we're not unnecessarily
running any resources and paying for it
if you're being interviewed for the
infra site in azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are windows active
directory and azure active
directory different let's talk about the
windows active directory first
the non-cloud windows active directory
was
the service was released along with
windows 2000 server edition
and this active directory is essentially
a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computers and a lot more it
provides authentication
and authorization to the applications
not only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and a lot of
other on-premises
resources that's what the basic
non-cloud active directory does
on the other hand the azure active
directory is not designed
to manage web-based services the azure
active directory on the other hand was
designed to support
web-based services that use rest api
interfaces for office 365
salesforce.com etc unlike the plain
active directory this uses a completely
different
protocol so protocol wise it's different
and the services that it support is
quite different now besides that it also
has couple of other differences as well
and let's look at them so the actual
active directory or the windows actual
directory is a directory service that
facilitates working with
interconnected complex and different
network resources
in a very unified manner on the other
hand azure active directory
is microsoft's multi-tenant cloud-based
directory and identity management
service and the windows active directory
has
five layers to store data to store user
details and
to issue the management certifications
on the other hand
azure active directory integrates or
compresses the five layers into
just two layers here windows active
directory
works with on-premises servers like
applications file servers and printers
etc on the other hand azure active
directory
it works on web-based services that use
restful interfaces if you're being hired
for the development
environment or for the cloud devops
support environment or even for the
production support environment
you might find yourself being asked this
question what are the types of
queues offered by azure now azure
supports two types of
queue mechanisms the storage queue and
the service bus
queue let's talk about storage queue
first now the storage queue
which are part of azure storage
infrastructure it provides a simple
rest based interface simple rest based
get put and peak interface it provides
reliable
persistent messaging within and between
other services
it follows the pub sub model or a pub
sub
messaging infrastructure and it's best
suited for users that need to store more
than 80 gigabit of messages in the queue
it can provide a logs for all the
transactions
executed against the user's queue so
that's what we get with
storage queue and on the other hand
service bus cue
the service bus queues are built on top
of broader messaging infrastructure
and they are designed to integrate
applications and
applications component that can span
multiple communication
protocols so that way it differs so this
is good for applications and components
that may span
multiple communication protocols and
even
different totally different network
environments so in short these service
buses
or the service bus queues in azure are
part of
azure's messaging infrastructure and
they
integrate applications or application
components that can
actually span multiple different
protocols and multiple different network
environments it also provides and first
and first out style for delivery and the
user's queue size has to remain
under 80 gigabit another familiar
question is what are the advantages of
azure resource manager now this resource
manager helps us to manage
at the usage of the application
resources this question is actually to
test how well have you
tested how well have you used resource
manager and have gotten the benefit of
it
this question actually tests how easy it
has become
after the introduction of resource
manager compared to
when doing deployments or when
provisioning resources
without the resource manager so let's
get into the answers for the question
what are the advantages of azure
resource manager the
in chart resource manager is called arm
so the arm helps deploy manage and
monitor all the resources
for an application a solution or a group
so
all the interconnected application all
interconnected services can be
monitored as group using resource
manager and
users can be granted to access to
resources that they require within a
resource manager so in an account
i can have like 10 different resources
created by
a resource manager or a resource group
created by resource managers and i can
allow deny connection to those services
or only to those services
based on whether the user should be
accessing one and not accessing the
other
so that way it becomes easy to give
access to a group
of application it helps in getting
billing details
for the group of resources now which
group is using
more which group is using less and which
group has contributed
more to this month's bill stuff like
that so those details can be obtained
using azure zos manager and provisioning
resources is
made much easier with the help of this
resource manager another question is
how has integrating hybrid cloud been
useful for azure well with the use of
hybrid cloud
we get the best of both the worlds so
what's hybrid cloud
it's nothing but combining the public
cloud and the private cloud and allowing
data and applications to be shared
between them so whenever the compute or
the processing demand fluctuates
hybrid cloud computing gives businesses
the
ability to seamlessly scale their
on-premises infrastructure
in the public cloud and handle any kind
of
overflow in the requirement or overflow
in handling the application so it really
helps it helps
it boost the productivity of our
on-premises
application so with the hybrid cloud we
get a greater efficiency
with combination of azure services
devops processes and tools for
the application running in on premises
and
by having an hybrid cloud environment
users can take advantage of
a constantly updated azure service and
other aws marketplace
applications for their on-premises
environment and the other benefit is uh
with hybrid cloud environment we can
simply deploy applications regardless of
its locations
in case of on-premises we'll have to
worry about the location but
when we expand our on-premises
environment in the cloud and they can or
we can pick any of the locations and
simply deploy it
in them and this enables the
applications to be
created at a greater speed what's
federating in azure sql now this
question is
very specific about sql how can we scale
the sql
database now this is a very good
question or a valid question or an
important question in the interview
because
many customers or companies have not
been able to meet the user demand
because they could not scale out
the databases the theory of scaling out
or adding servers
to accommodate the increased workloads
and traffic
is not hard to understand but the
implications can be very complicated the
implications can be
very expensive we're well aware of
scaling the web servers that's very
common
but how do we scale the database so
microsoft
provides the tools and technologies so
we can scale out
the database in the cloud and that's
what is called sql or
federation in azure sql so the way we
scale
out the sql database is by sharing
sharding the database so sharding
actually enables users to take
advantages of the resources in the cloud
not only that it allows users to have
their own database or a shared
database amongst each other because
we're creating a highly available
database because we're having shards in
a database it actually reduces the
possibility
of a single point of failure for our
database and more importantly because
we're starting
because we're using federation and azure
sql it provides an
cost effective scaling of our databases
by using cloud resources
or by using billing only for the cloud
resources
that we have used so no pre-provisioning
no
over provisioning it provisions the
right amount and we pay the right amount
let's talk about this one what are the
different types of storage offered
by azure now the different types of
storage offered by azure are as you
already know and as you can see
they are azure blob storages table
storages
file storage and queue storage so let's
expand
one after the other now blob storage are
nothing but a massive
scalable object storage and that's very
good for storing text and
binary data and azure blob storage is a
microsoft object storage solution for
the cloud a
blob storage is optimized for storing
massive
massive amount of unstructured data that
can be
in form of text or or in form of binary
data
so in short blob storage enables users
to store
unstructured data and those data can be
in the format of pictures music video
files
and lot more and it stores them along
with their metadata
and another advantage or another feature
benefit that we get from blob storage
is when object is changed it is verified
to ensure
it is of the latest version number one
and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
user's storage
needs and this unstructured data is
available to customers through an url
or an rest based object storage so they
are the benefits that come along
with the blob storage table storage on
the other hand is an
a nosql store for schema-less storage of
secured data now this azure table
storage is a service
that stores uh structured no sql data in
the cloud
and because this table is schema-less
it's very easy to
save your data it's very easy to adapt
your data
as the need for your application grows
and this table storage is very fast
and cost effective for many type of
applications
so some of the some of the type of data
that we can store
is table storage is good for flexible
databases like
user data for web applications address
book
storage device information storage and
if you want to store
metadata this is a very good use case to
store them
in azure table storage azure files is
another storage
uh here it's an managed file share for
cloud
or on premises deployment so file
storage provides the file sharing
capabilities
accessible by the server messaging block
protocol and this can be accessed from
the cloud and this can be accessed from
on premises as well
here in file storage the data is
protected by smb
3.0 and https protocols and
the more important thing is azure takes
care of managing hardware
and the operating system deployments for
azure file storage
so this additional file storage can be
used when we want to burst the storage
capacity in on premises
so on premises the primary and cloud is
the secondary or the extended
on-premises storage
so it actually improves the on-premises
performance and capabilities
for our on-premises data center and then
we have
queues azure queues it's a messaging
store for reliable messaging between
the application components we spoke a
little about this
uh in the previous question so the azure
queue storage is a service for storing
a large amount of messages that can be
accessed from
anywhere in the world via http or https
protocol in here the a single message
can be up to 64 kilobits in size
and in a queue we can have millions
of messages and the limit can actually
go up if we have not reached the limit
of the storage account so it's millions
and millions
of requests that can be stored in the
storage tube or the queue storage
so the queue storage in short provides
message
queuing for large workloads and it
enables users to build flexible
applications and separate
the functions one from another so one
failing
doesn't affect the other application
which is
running healthy and this q storage it
ensures the application is scalable and
less prone
to individual component failures because
they are
decoupled separate now it also helps in
monitoring the queue which ensures the
customer's demands are
met so queue is a great place to monitor
or a great component to monitor so we
understand
how much peak have we reached for a
particular application
service or a container what is text
analysis api
in azure machine learning now a text
analysis is
actually an cloud based analytics
api and it provides an advanced natural
language processing over the raw text
and it has got
four main functions like the sentiment
analysis or and the key phrase analysis
language uh deduction and few other
things now what do you mean by sentiment
analysis now sentiment analysis is from
the logs from the comments from the
text comments that we receive do an
analysis
and find out whether that's a positive
or a
negative statement now if it is a the
api the api returns and
sentiment score between 0 and 1 and
1 is positive and 0 is negative
and then in text analysis we have a key
phrase
extraction which is it will
automatically
extract the key phrase to uh quickly
identify the main points in that key
phrase
for example if you're analyzing an text
which says the food was delicious and
there were wonderful stuff then the api
returns the main talking points of that
phrase like food
food is the main talking point and
wonderful stuffs that was a main talking
point so
that's another feature that this text
analysis has and then we have language
deduction
in text analysis but irrespective of
what you
paste it can try to gauge and try to
align
it to the 120 or up to 120 languages
that it
supports so i can simply take text from
the internet and i can paste it
and text analysis software is going to
identify the language
and then can run phrase and sentiment
analysis
on those texts right so in short text
analysis
is an api a set of web services that can
be used for
text analysis it can be used to analyze
unstructured
statement sentiment analysis key phrase
extraction
and lot more and the results are
generally between 0 and 1
and 1 being positive and 0 being the
negative sentiment
there is no much training or in other
words this is not as complicated
as couple of other text analysis
softwares are available in the market
we can simply paste we can simply upload
the text and we can call the service
and it runs a sentiment analysis on it
all by itself
let's look at this question what are the
advantages of azure queue storage
if you're going to work on a development
environment if you're going to work on
an environment that
embraces devops this could be a question
what are the advantages of azure
queue storage now azure queue storage
is built to flexibly operate the
applications
and separate the functions between the
applications
that run large workloads so when we
design applications for scale
these applications can be decoupled so
that they can scale
independently you know and thing
happening on an application
is not dependent on another application
and anything happens to an
section of the application will not
affect the other application because
they are now
decoupled and connected through the
queue storage
so the queue storage gives us
asynchronous message
queuing for communication between the
applications
irrespective of whether they are running
in the cloud or whether they are running
in desktop or whether they are running
on premises
or on mobile devices so in short this
queue storage
enables message queueing for large
workloads in a simple
and cost effective and a durable manner
talking about the advantages
advantages is it provides rich client
libraries for java android c plus plus
php
ruby and lot other services getting
added
during every new release from azure and
the main advantage again is it enables
users to
build flexible apps and separate the
functions
for bigger or greater durability
again introduction of queues into our
application it
ensures our users applications are
scalable
and less prone to individual component
failures meaning
one component failing is not going to
take the whole application down
right if one component fails it's just
that component that stays fails the rest
are healthy and the rest are going to
function it also helps us to monitor the
queues and ensure the servers aren't
overhelmed
by sudden traffic bursts so how much do
i have
in the cube kind of determines the
traffic
for my application and if the queue is
more i can always go and auto scale my
environment and the queue is less i can
always go and shrink
or make my environment thinner so it can
save cost and anytime there is more data
in the queue
i can auto scale monitor the metric and
do auto scaling based on that metric
so the environment knows that there are
more data's coming in
i need to expand myself to handle that
much amount of
data this is a very common question what
are the two kinds of azure
web service roles now a service role is
a set of managed and load balanced
virtual machines
that work to perform some tasks and
based on
what it's going to run on top of it is
it going to run a web service or is it
going to run a worker service
defines what kind of roles that gets
attached
or that goes on this virtual machines so
we have two types web role
and worker roles the web role is a cloud
service
role that's configured to run web
applications developed on programming
languages technologies
and majorly they support iis internet
information service
and they support asp.net php
windows communication foundation and so
on so that's web
roles and these web roles it
automatically deploys and hosts
application
through the users iis internet
information service on the other hand
worker roles
are roles that runs applications and
service level tasks
which generally do not require iis so
iis
is actually the differentiating factor
so in worker roles iis is not installed
by default the worker roles
are mainly used to perform supporting
background process
along with web roles and do tasks
automatically compressing
or uploading the images running scripts
and are doing some changes in the
database getting new messages from the
queue
and processing a lot more you know the
work the applications
are the work that does not require ies
that's what
this worker role does again
the main difference between the web role
and the worker role is that
the web role automatically deploys and
hosts your application through is
whereas the worker role does not use ies
and
runs our application as standalone this
is another classic question what is
azure
service fabric so azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to pack
deploy and manage
scalable and reliable micro services and
containers
now service fabric also addresses some
of the significant challenges in
developing
and managing cloud native applications
and the problem that it addresses and
fixes
is now developers and administrators can
avoid complex infrastructure problems
and focus on
implementing mission critical and
demanding workloads that can be scaled
and that can be managed through the
console or from the
single place in short service fabric
provides a platform
that makes the process of developing
microservices
and managing application life cycle a
lot
easier and the advantages of service
fabric is that
now we can produce application with
faster time to market because all the
worry about the infrastructure is taken
away from us we don't have to design an
infrastructure
all that we need to worry about is
simply the application and the
application
life cycle again the advantage is it
supports
windows it supports linux not only that
it supports
servers on-premises and in the cloud
with service fabric
we can scale up our environment to even
thousand machines in just a single
command or
if there is a immediate need for a
thousand machines i can immediately
scale them up
2000 machines that's possible with
service fabric now let's look at this
question you can expect this question if
the customer is running
hybrid environment meaning having some
of the applications and on-premises
and running some of the applications
from the cloud and for some reason
when classifying the application that
goes to the cloud and that stays on
premises
they have decided to keep the database
in-house so in that environment a lot of
customers do that so in that
environment this is a classic and a
scenario based question a client wants
the front end of their application to be
hosted on azure
in the cloud and wants the database to
be hosted in on-premises
for security reasons or to have full
control on their databases
how do we go about suggesting a solution
for this customer
the ideal solution in this scenario is
to use
the v-net based point-to-site vpn
solution so all the front-end
applications will be in the cloud
and they'll be hosted in a v-net and
from the we net they'll be connecting to
the
database through and point to site vpn
so the traffic and the writings and the
reads are not
coming through the internet but through
a point to site
vpn link that's connecting the azure
v-net
and the on-premises environment and this
model or this approach or this solution
is best suited for scenarios
where there are only a limited number of
resource that needs to be connected
between on-premises and the cloud this
is a very common question
what's azure traffic manager of course
we no more running applications on a
single
server we no more running applications
on or or from a single environment right
the same application is being
run from multiple environments within
azure and
it can be running from azure and
on-premise as well so multiple
environments between azure and
on-premises
and a lot of customers have such
environment and if you are facing an
interview
with such customer this could be an
ideal question what is azure traffic
manager now the azure traffic manager is
a dns based
traffic load balancer that actually
enables us to distribute
traffic between services across azure
global regions and by doing this it
provides
a good availability and a good
responsiveness
to the application and this traffic
manager it uses dns
to direct client requests to the most
appropriate
service endpoint based on the traffic
routing logic
and the health of the endpoints that it
maintains
so in short this traffic manager is a
load balancer that enables
users to provide high availability and
responsiveness by distributing traffic
in an
optimal manner across the azure when we
run the same application in different
regions
so some of the advantages or some of the
use cases of using azure traffic manager
is
it provides multiple automatic failover
options
it also helps with reduced downtime it
also helps with the distribution of
user traffic across multiple locations
so one location
is not overloaded and then it helps with
users
knowing from where our customers are
getting connected from
that's another big use case with azure
traffic manager let's look at this
question
right this is an ideal question now
there are group of servers connected
together
within an virtual network and now we
need to
move them or create a separation between
them how do you go about
achieving it so the question goes like
this you need to isolate
network traffic among vms in a subnet
which is part of a virtual network with
little downtime and impact on the user
so that's the given scenario
and the best way we can do it is create
a new virtual network and move all the
vms
in that subnet to the new virtual
network now
this feature is not possible with a lot
of other cloud service providers like
aws and a lot of other providers
now in those environments we might need
to
shut down we might need to stop the vm
create a new vm based on the image
and it's an hefty process but here in
azure
i can simply move the vms from one
subnet
to another virtual network without
needing for any additional
security like the network security group
i can simply isolate them
if i need to by creating a simple new
virtual network and moving the
servers to the new virtual network look
at this one this is another common
question
with respect to azure what is public
private and hybrid
cloud so this is really to test how well
have you understood the different cloud
offerings in the market
public private and hybrid or at least
the three basic offerings in the market
public private and hybrid cloud now the
public cloud is the most
common way of deploying cloud computing
applications
and it has resources like servers
storage
and are owned and operated by
third-party cloud service providers
like microsoft azure microsoft azure is
a very good example of
public cloud so here every component
that the user is using
is running only on azure that's public
cloud
let me talk to you about some of the
advantages of public cloud some of the
advantages is
low cost because there's no need to
purchase hardware or software
and we pay only for the services that we
use in public cloud
and there is literally no maintenance
because
the service provider maintains the
environment for us
and with public cloud we have nearly
unlimited
scalability meaning we can get resources
on demand and can meet our business
requirements
on demand and the public clouds are very
highly
reliable because they have a vast
network of servers
and they ensure that our application
does not fail so there are some
advantages
of public cloud let's talk about private
cloud now private cloud
consists of compute resources used
extensively by
one business or one organization now
this private cloud can be
physically located at our organization's
on-site data
center or it can be hosted by a
third-party service
provider whichever the case the private
cloud services and infrastructure are
always
maintained on a private network and
they're maintained on hardware and
software that are
dedicated solely for one organization or
solely
for your organization so in short
private cloud in azure is azure services
being run within an on-premises data
center
or on-premises data center used by
the user to host systems or applications
and some of the advantages some of the
advantages is
it gives more security resources are not
shared with others
so a higher level of control and
security over our resource and
application is possible
and then we have hybrid cloud now hybrid
cloud is the best of both
worlds so it combines the features of
both public and
private cloud and some of the user
components are being run on azure
and others within on-premises data
center so they kind of share
the resources in other words they kind
of share the application half of the
application would be running in
on-premises and half of them
would be in the cloud and they would be
working in harmony
to support the application and the
business need so that's hybrid cloud
this is one another good example
question
that wants to test how well you pick
services or how well have you understood
the azure
products and services and are picking
the right service for the need so the
question would go like this what kind of
storage is best suited to handle
unstructured
data there are a lot of storage options
available and the requirement here is
what or which one would you choose for
unstructured data
the answer for that question is blob
storage because blob storage is designed
to support unstructured data it works in
this way it places the data into
different tiers based on how often
they are accessed different tier means
different performance different
performance means different
cost associated with it so a lot of
add-on
advantages will be get when we use blob
storage for unstructured data in
addition to it
any type of unstructured data can be
stored in blob
storage this is not true with couple of
other storage options that we have in
azure
only with blob storage we can store any
type of unstructured data and the data
integrity is maintained every time an
object is
changed in the blob storage and the best
part is
the blob storage helps increase
applications performance
and reduces the bandwidth consumption
and reduces the bandwidth consumption
for that application so there are the
benefits that we get for block storage
and blob storage
are the ones that are well suited for
unstructured data
and that's what your answer should be
it's really an five-step
process and if you're worked and if we
have done some labs some basic labs with
azure you can easily answer this
question so it's a five-step process
first step is to log into the azure the
second one is to create
an uh resource a resource or a resource
manager and within the resource manager
you will be selecting the resource
and then pick the uh operating system do
you want windows or linux and within
windows what's the flavor you want or
within linux what's the flavor you want
to decide on it
and then entering the relevant
information relevant information
like the name of the
instance or the vm that we're going to
launch and the password
the url that goes with it and couple of
other relevant information that goes
gets itself attached with the vm and
then select the size of the virtual
machine different
size different uh types available for
the kind of application
and for the intensity of the application
that will be running on top of
it so select the virtual select the size
of the virtual machine
review everything whether they're good
or not
if there are any changes required go
back and edit them and then come back
and launch
and your vm is there for you to start
working within
like three or four minutes not even five
minutes within three or four minutes
it gets ready and you can start working
on it so it's a quick
and it's a five step process and you
should be able to answer it
easily if you have done a few labs uh in
azure
let's now look at some scenario based
question you've been posted with a
scenario
so we thought through it and we picked
some common scenario based
question that are being asked in
interview and i thought we'll present it
for you
with the answers with explanation so you
can get
benefited through it so let's look at
this question
you're asked to make sure your virtual
machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do
and the correct and the best answer for
this would be using
virtual network in azure which enables
us to communicate with the internet
securely
which enables us to communicate with the
on-premises data center in a secure
fashion so the
advantage of using virtual network is
users can create their own private
network users can pick their own private
ip ranges
users can create their own subnet users
can create their own routing
between those two subnets a lot more
goes into that
virtual network so it's very
customizable
and the users are provided with an
isolated and highly secure
environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications
that are running in other virtual
network that we own
so within our account we can have
multiple virtual networks and
one application running on a virtual
machine is completely isolated from
other applications running on other
virtual machines
and of course all traffic stays within
the azure network as your virtual
machine or within the azure network
depending on how you set up
the routing if you have set up a routing
to go
or reach the internet it's going to go
otherwise it's going to stay
within azure if you have set up routing
to reach on-premises then it's going to
go
and reach on-premises otherwise it's not
going to go and reach on-premises it's
going to stay
within the azure and it also allows
users to design their own network like
we already discussed picking up ips
picking
routing you know picking subnets you
know how many servers
should be present in that particular
subnet or how many servers should that
subnet accommodate
the size of the subnet the ip ranges the
netting the masking of ips
creating of vpn all that's possible with
the virtual network so it really allows
users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure
applications in the cloud let's look at
this other scenario
how do you ensure that every time a user
logs in they are not asked to re-enter
the password as part of authentication
so you really don't want your users to
re-enter
the password every time they log in to a
different
application well all the applications
have their
authentication mechanism in place all of
them wants to
authenticate the user before they log in
ensuring the user does not
log in every time does not mean that
wiping away all the authentication and
authorization that's present
in that application you still need that
in place but how do you make the
user hassle free so they're not asked to
re-enter the password or the same
password again and again
let's look at the options available the
first one is to enable microsoft account
authentication
well it's not going to fix because with
that the user will still need to
re-enter the username and password
deploy express route it's not going to
fix either because
express route is a network level service
that connects on-premises
to the cloud so that has got nothing to
do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have
set up vpn between on-premises data
center
and azure setup 80 domain controller in
vm
and implement integrated windows
authentication well
you can use the same username and
password
for on-premises and the cloud but
this setup the vpn and the ad controller
set up it's not going to
stop you asking for repetitive passwords
so this is all about using the same
password in on premises
and in the cloud and this has got
nothing to do with
not prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right so that's
same password is different from not
prompting the user
to re-enter the password they are two
different scenarios so
that is also out of the equation and the
last one is configure
ad sync to use single sign-on that's the
right one
so when we configure the ad to use a
single sign on
then it's going it's not going to ask
for the username and password every time
we access an application because we have
logged in
and that login is going to stay active
for like 24 hours or so depending on how
you configure it and within that
time you can access a lot of other
applications and it's not going to ask
for the username and password because
you already have a single signed on and
you have signed in
using the right credentials let's look
at this one you need to ensure that
virtual machines remain available
while migrating to azure what would be
the appropriate
service to use right let's look at the
options traffic manager
traffic manager is is literally and dna
service
and then let's look at the other one
update domains
it again has to do with traffic manager
updating the url
so now the traffic manager gets updated
and then starts sending requests
to that particular url it's going to
take
some downtime because when we update the
url they will have to be populated
to all different places and it takes
time so within that time
any user trying to access it's going to
fail and then we have
express route and cloud services express
route could be the
in fact it's the right answer because
express route it's an extension of our
on-premises and cloud environment
and in this question it really comes out
from
a customer who's having an hybrid
environment so they have applications
running
in on-premises they have applications
running in the cloud and
they want to have a way to migrate
applications from on-premises to the
cloud in other words kind of do a
cutover
between on-premises and the cloud and
this express route is a service that
connects between on premises
and the cloud so when you do the cut
over the traffic is now sent to the
cloud instead of being handled in on
premises
in fact the services and the application
is getting down are getting shut down
in on premises so the request will come
in the same pattern
instead of they being handled in
on-premises
they are now routed to the cloud using
express route and the
api calls get addressed or the the
queries gets answered
in the cloud through the express route
service look at this question you are an
administrator
for a website called web game and you
are required to validate
and deploy changes made to your website
by your
development team with minimum downtime
so the real question is how do you
validate
the deployment changes that's made by
the development team
let's look at the options create a new
linked resource
create a staging environment for the
site
enable remote debugging on the website
and then create a new website well why
would you want to create a new website
just to validate the changes and doing a
remote debugging is not going to help
because debugging only captures logs of
the changes happening it does not do
anything with validating the changes
create a staging environment could be or
is
the right answer because when we have
staging environments
anything that we run on production can
be run on staging environment
and any failures that would happen in
production if we simply run it in
production
can be captured when we run the
application in the staging environment
so that way
staging environment is a very helpful
and useful service
and that way i can catch any errors
in other words i can validate the
changes that were done by my
development team before i move it to
production and that reduces
the downtime in the production
environment look at this one last
question
that we have for you it's um a standard
tier application is used across the
world
and uses azure website standard tier it
uses large amount of image files so
you can get it this could be an
e-commerce website which has a lot of
pictures in it and this is causing the
application to load slow
how can we handle this situation let's
look at the options given
configure blob storage with custom
domain well this application has
pictures
but the pictures only the pictures is
not all that the application has
all right so configuring blob storage
might not
help this could be an very interactive
website and that can't be run from blob
storage let's look at the other options
configure azure
website auto scaling to increase
instances
at high loads now it's the picture
that's causing
issues for the website it's not the cpu
or it's not the memory
unavailable memory not enough that's
causing the application to be slow so we
need to identify what's causing the
application to be slow so it's not the
cpu it's not the memory
so configure azure for auto scaling is
not going to help
and then what are the other options
let's see configure azure cdn
to cache all responses from the
application's
web endpoint a cdn could be the right
answer but
look at that it says a cdn to cache all
responses from the applications web
endpoint
cdn is not designed for that though it
can do it that's not the best way to
use cdn to capture all responses from
the application's web endpoint the
proper design for cdn
would be to cache the frequently used
ones
in other words cache the static content
which are photos videos logos and
pictures and lot more static content
that never changes
let's look at the last option configure
azure cdn to cache
site images and content stored in azure
blob storage absolutely correct so here
we will have to redesign
the application to store the pictures
high quality lazy loading or slow
loading pictures
because of the high quality and the
bigger size so store them
in cdn and then the content let it be
stored in azure blob storage that's the
right
way of designing the application and if
we do it this application is going to
run faster or the application is going
to respond
faster to the users and with that we
have come to the end of this video on
microsoft as your full course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here